hey guys welcome to this react developer
full course video
react js is a widely used front-end
development library if you're just
starting or you wish to brush up on your
basics then you're in the right place
this video will cover all the concepts
of react.js
so let's look at what's in store for us
first we'll look at what react.js is
then we'll understand how to install and
setup react environment
then we'll move on to learn the
fundamental concepts of components props
and state
we will then look at a tutorial video to
develop two applications that are
spotify app and the calculator app using
react.js
after that we look at the differences
between the javascript frameworks react
angular and view
we're also going to look at topics like
how to connect react.js with node.js
and understand how redux can be used
with react from there we learn about the
most widely used react extension for
mobile development that is react native
followed by which we'll look at the
differences between react native and
flutter
and finally we'll end this session by
looking at the top yak js interview
questions but before we begin if you
haven't subscribed to our channel
already make sure to subscribe and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
i'm sure you're excited to learn so
let's dive right in let's go ahead and
begin with what is react react is a
javascript library used to build fast
and interactive user interfaces for both
web and mobile applications now one
thing that makes react extremely
powerful is the fact that it's open
source any user can access its source
code modify it and enhance it in a
typical model view controller
architecture react defines the view part
of the application it is also
responsible for how the app looks and
feels fun fact react was built by jordan
walkey an engineer at facebook now let's
go ahead and see how react works in real
time consider a typical web application
say instagram the entire ui of the web
page is divided into several components
we have the search component a profile
description component stories component
and a post list component these
components make the code easier to debug
and always remain discreet components
also make development and maintenance of
web applications faster as multiple
developers can work simultaneously on
different components of the same web
application now let's see why react is
so popular these days the act helps in
creation of dynamic web applications it
also provides performance enhancements
now there are several performance
enhancements like virtual dom and
one-way data binding we'll learn about
these topics a little later in the video
react uses reusable components now this
helps decrease the development time
react involves unidirectional flow of
data react also has a small learning
curve compared to other frameworks like
angular react is much easier to learn
react can also be used for mobile
applications react recently released an
extension called react native that is
used for developing mobile applications
that are cross-compatible it also has
dedicated tools for easy debugging now
let's dive in to the features of react
first let's understand jsx jsx is a
syntax extension to javascript using jsx
we can add html to the javascript file
all coding in react is done using jsx it
also helps in making the code easier to
understand and debug ultimately jsx is a
combination of javascript and html now
let's consider a small example cons
simple here is a javascript notation h1
tags indicate html again the semicolon
indicates javascript note that the
semicolon is not mandatory however it's
a good practice to include it moving on
the next feature is virtual dom dom
which is an acronym for data object
model actually defines how documents are
accessed and manipulated in a web page
it represents the entire structure of
the web page in the form of a tree
now let's see how this actually works
react creates a virtual dom that is the
exact copy of the real dom traditionally
whenever something changes in the web
application all objects in the real dom
are updated this makes it extremely slow
let's see how react counters this now
consider two objects whose states have
been changed react now compares the
virtual dom with the virtual dom
snapshot that was taken right before the
update by comparing the new virtual dom
with the pre-update version react
figures out exactly which virtual dom
objects have changed now react only
updates those objects on the virtual dom
this makes a big difference when it
comes to speed coming to the next
feature performance react uses virtual
dom as discussed earlier virtual dog
impacts the speed of the web
applications we also took an example of
instagram and learned how multiple
components can affect the development
time they help improve performance
drastically the next feature is one way
data binding this means information
flows in only one direction one way data
binding is specifically used when
information is displayed and not updated
remember that the components of react
are functional in nature that is they
receive information through arguments
and pass information via their return
values the next important feature is
extensions react has many extensions
that we can use to create full-fledged
front-end applications it provides
server-side rendering which means that
the application is rendered on the
server rather than in the browser react
native which is a react extension is
used for developing mobile applications
there are many other extensions that
react provides for every scenario in web
development now let's look at a few of
them react native lets you build mobile
applications using only javascript a
react native app is a real mobile
application and not just a web
application running on your mobile
devices thousands of applications like
facebook instagram pinterest skype use
react native the next popular react
extension is flux flux is the
application architecture that facebook
uses flux implements unidirectional flow
which makes it easier to understand what
actually is going on now let's see how
it works when we trigger an action the
dispatcher will get notified the
dispatcher receives actions and
dispatches them to the stores a store is
what holds the data of an application
stores will register with the
application's dispatcher so that they
can receive actions data from stores is
displayed in views actions define the
internal api of your application they
capture how anything might interact with
your application the last feature of
react is debugging react applications
are easy to debug thanks to the large
and active developer community you can
practically debug react codes within
your browser now notice the small react
extension icon at the top right corner
this developer tool allows the user to
inspect the code and also easily debug
it moving on let's learn about the
building blocks of react components
state and props are the essential
concepts that one should know before
implementing react they are the
foundation on which react is built now
what exactly are react components
components are the building blocks of
any react application react divides the
user interface into multiple components
wherein each component defines how a
particular element is viewed in the
application react components remain
discrete and are processed independently
another feature is reusability
components can be reused multiple times
across the application this reduces the
development time consider the following
code snippet a component is implemented
as a javascript class having some state
and a render method state is the data
which we want the component to render
the render method is responsible for how
the ui looks and feels to the user the
next concept is state state of a
component is an object that holds some
data this data influences the output of
a component every time the state of an
object changes the component is
re-rendered onto the screen now let's
see what props are props or short for
properties allow us to pass arguments or
data to components properties help make
components more dynamic it is important
to define all the properties their types
and their default value props are passed
to components in a way similar to that
of html tag attributes now consider the
following code snippets this shows
exactly how properties are passed to
components also detailed illustrations
on components props and state will be
shown in the upcoming videos so stay
tuned for that
moving on let's go through some of the
things that you should know before you
can actually start working on react you
should be familiar with programming
concepts like functions objects arrays
and classes one should also have a basic
knowledge of javascript and a
familiarity with html don't worry if you
feel like you're not good at them once
you start working on them you'll get a
good hang of it finally let's go through
the impact of react on the it industry
and get insights into the salaries of
react developers statistics show that
react developers earn way more than
other web developers according to pay
scale the average salary for a react
developer in the united states is a
whopping 91 000 us dollars the average
salary for a react developer in india is
7.25 lakhs per annum over the recent
years react has gained immense
popularity and is being adopted by many
companies according to the data by
google trends react has had a better
growth scale compared to other
frameworks like angular and vue
statistics show that front-end
developers have wholeheartedly adopted
this lightweight framework forgoing
other available options if you are
skilled and have a knack for front-end
development react can help you gain
fantastic career opportunities lastly
talking about a few companies that use
react devotionally we have facebook
instagram netflix dropbox whatsapp among
others to set up the react development
environment we need two things installed
node and a text editor of your choice so
let's begin by installing node.js we can
head to the official node.js website
save download
node.js so here you can see the windows
installer depending on your system you
can either download the 32-bit version
or the 64-bit version so i'm going to go
ahead and click on the 64-bit version
since it's already installed on my
system i'm not again installing node you
can follow the installation guidelines
and download it once you're done with
node installation you can go ahead and
download a text editor of your choice so
i'd suggest vs code so let's head to the
vs code page say download vs code click
on the first link and download the
64-bit version for windows once you're
done with the installation of both node
and your text editor you can start
creating your first react application so
for that let's create a folder
i'm creating it on my desktop while you
can create it in any of your drives
let's call it
first
react now open your command prompt now
you can type in the path for the folder
that you just created
so say
cd
users
first react now go ahead and type in the
command npm
install
hyphen g create
react
app okay so this command installs all
the necessary react.js modules now to
check if the version is correctly
installed you can type in create
react app
version so you can see the version here
now let's continue and develop your
react application type in the command
create
react app
and you can give a name to your
application so i say my app
now this should take a couple of minutes
okay once you've successfully created an
application
they say to begin by typing the
following commands so let's do that save
cd my app and npm start this should
typically start your application and
here we go
all right you can also open your
application in the text editor that
you've downloaded so let's go ahead and
open vs code vs code file
open folder go to your desktop or the
drive that you saved your folder in
first react
my app and i say select folder so as you
can see all your modules have been
imported you can click on app.js and
start editing what exactly are
components components are the building
blocks of a react application wherein
each component represents a part of the
user interface now to make it more
understandable consider the facebook
home page the entire ui can be broken
down into several elements say we have
the credentials component the sign up
component the image component and the
logo component notice that each
component adds something to how the home
page looks alright reusability is one of
the salient features of react components
one component can be reused several
times across the application and this
improves the development speed
components can also be nested one
component can internally consist of
several other components in its minimal
form a component must define a render
method that specifies how exactly the
application looks and feels a component
can also receive properties from its
parent components also you'll get a
better understanding of all of these
when we start working hands-on so don't
worry so moving on let's look at the
different types of components first we
have the stateless functional components
and then we have the stateful class
components now functional components are
typical javascript functions that return
html now they can be contained in a dot
js or a dot jsx file coming to class
components these are regular es6 classes
however it's mandatory that they contain
a render method that in turn returns
html they can also be contained in dot
jx or dot jsx file okay then let's go
ahead and build our first react
application using components alright so
i've opened my text editor that is vs
code to build my application
also i suggest you watch the react
installation on windows video to help
you get started the video briefly
explains how to install node and how to
start building your first react
application in my case i've opened a
folder called react component tutorial
and here in my source folder i have
app.js now app.js is the main component
that gets rendered to the dom let me
show you that here in index.js you pass
app.js which is a component that gets
rendered to the react dom so app.js
consists of several other components
that can be nested so as you can see
app.js is a functional component and
before moving on let me get rid of all
the unnecessary code so let me delete
all of this
and return
an h1 tag that says hello welcome to
simply let me save it and if you look at
the browser you'll have hello welcome to
simply learn now let's go ahead and
display another message say h1
this
video is about
components let me save it and let me
check the browser it gives you an error
so jsx uses a conventional rule which
states that all html tags have to be
enclosed within a div tag so for example
i say div
and i enclose it so let me save and
check my browser again here you go so
multiple html tags have to be enclosed
within the div tag moving on let's
create a first functional component to
do that i'll first create a folder in my
source folder say components within that
i'll create a file say functional
component dot js all right so the first
thing we have to do is import react so i
say import react from
yeah the general syntax for a functional
component involves the keyword function
and say
functional
component
now you say return an h1 tag or i've
already used h1 tags so i'll say
paragraph and i say
this is
a functional component all right before
explaining to you how these components
are exported and imported let me show
you the general syntax for a class
component so i create another file say
class component dot js i again import
react from react the general notation is
using the class keyword followed by the
name of the class extending from the
base class the act dot component so
going ahead i say class class component
extends react dot component now the key
feature of a class component is the
usage of a render method so i say render
within braces i say return a paragraph
tag saying this is
the class component all right so moving
on let's see how these components can be
nested into the main component that is
app.js components can be nested into the
main component using import and export
keywords so as the name suggests export
feature is used to export a particular
file or a module and import is used to
import a particular file or module into
the current existing module so we have
two different types of exports you have
default export and just export or named
export so a default export is used to
export just one object be it a function
a class a variable from the file and
there can only be one default export per
file and when you're importing it you
can specify the address and use the word
import before it so let me show you how
it works let's go back to our editor and
then functional component and here i say
export default and the name of the
functional component that is
functional com so let me save this and
going back to my app.js i say import
name of the functional component that is
functional com from and i pass the path
this components slash functional
component also let me get rid of these
unnecessary
files here now let's define functional
component in our app.js component so
here
i say functional com let's compile it
and check our browser here it says this
is a functional component moving on to
my class component it's the same syntax
here as well i say export default name
of my component and in my app.js i
import it
import class comp from the path and
again i'll have to define it in my
return method i save so let me compile
it and check my browser it says this is
the class component one unique feature
of default export is that i can rename
the file while i'm importing it so for
example i can rename it as say fc and
while i'm defining it i'll have to make
sure i use the same naming conventions
so i say fc again and when i check it it
says this is the functional component
there's literally no difference the next
type of export is the named export or
just export so a named export can be
used to export multiple objects be it
functions class etc from a file now
there can be several named exports from
a single file one hack is that while
you're importing it cannot be renamed so
let me show you how this works okay so
let's create another class in our class
component so i'll just copy paste this
let me give it another name say class
com1 and the message that i want to
display is hey i'm another class all
right so when i'm exporting it i don't
want default so let me take it off and
say export here all right
in my app.js while importing it i want
to import both the classes so i'll
include them within curly braces here i
say class com comma class comp one and
then again i define it here class comp
one let's compile it and run it and here
we go here you can see hey i'm another
class so we've successfully exported
both the classes from the class
component and imported it back in our
app.js component one advantage of using
named export is the fact that i can
choose to import the classes that i want
to now say for example i do not want to
import class component here so let me
take it off and here let me
comment this now let's compile and see
hey am another class the second class
got imported while the first class that
was defined earlier is not imported here
all right so next up we have higher
order and pure competence now i won't
get into the nativities of it because
they're advanced topics but to give you
a brief insight higher order components
are basically functions that take in a
component and return a new component the
whole ideology behind higher order
components is to facilitate the
reusability of component logic okay so
let's see how this works let's go back
to our code editor let's create a
component in our components folder let's
call the component
click
dot js all right so here we define a
class i use this snippet rce here we go
we get the entire format using the small
snippet rce and here i'm going to make
use of a button now see i use the tag
button and i'll say
clicked
one time every time the user clicks on
the button the value gets incremented so
for this i'm going to use a variable say
count and i'm going to use the concept
of states so let's go ahead and define
our variable count and initialize it to
zero so for that i'm going to use
another snippet called r const and here
this dot state equals my variable count
initializing it to zero so let's define
the count variable in a render method
so i say const count equals this dot
state so every time we click on the
button the count value has to get
incremented right so we make use of an
event called on click equals
this dot
update click
now update click is going to be another
method that we have to define now so
every time the button gets clicked this
method is called so let's go ahead and
define the function so it is update
click equals is going to be an arrow
function and i say
this dot set state is nothing but count
this dot
state dot count plus one okay and here
we say
count times all right so once this is
done let's import our component in
app.js so here again
i say import click from components click
and let's define it here so let's check
our browser every time we click on the
button the value gets incremented all
right so let's go ahead and create
another component say counter.js where
in every time the user hovers the mouse
on the button the count value increases
so let's go ahead and do that i say
counter dot js i'm again going to use
the snippet rce to create a class
component and here in my div tag i
define a button and say incremented
to for now i say x so now let's go ahead
and add the event say button
on
mouse
enter i'm going to call the method this
dot increment count okay so once you're
done with that let's go ahead and define
the increment count method i'm going to
copy the same code that i've mentioned
in my click.js so i say copy this all
right so one change is that i change the
name of the method and
call it increment count again let's
define the count in our render method so
i say const count equals
this dot state and here i change x to
now let's go ahead and import it in our
app.js so i say import counter
from
components and countdown and let's
define it here all right let's save it
and let's run the code okay so as you
can see you see another button here
incremented to zero and every time i
move my cursor on the button it
increments mind you i'm not clicking i'm
just hovering my mouse okay to learn how
higher order components work we'll have
to pass counter.js and click.js as
parameters to give birth to an entire
new component so for that let's go ahead
and create another component for our hoc
let's call it
higher order dot js okay so i say import
react
from react after that i say const
updated component equals
original component that's going to be an
arrow function again and within curly
braces i define my class that is class
say new component extends react
dot component inside let's define a
render method
that returns the original component with
a modification that is i want to type
the user i want to append the user
before the actual message is displayed
all right so let's go ahead and close
the tag and return new component and
let's export this say export
default updated component now we import
higherorder.js in our counter.js and
click.js and pass these components as
parameters so let's do that let's go to
our counter.js and here i say import
updated component
from
dot slash higher order component and
here while exporting i say updated comp
and pass this as my parameter let's do
the same to click.js here i import
data.com from higher order component and
here i pass this as a parameter now here
in a higher order component we've
defined a property name and initialized
it to the user so we'll have to include
this in our other components that's
counter and click so let's do that and
here right before incremented to i say
this dot props
dot name let me save it let me do the
same thing here and say this dot props
dot name so if you go back to our
browser here you can see it says the
user clicked zero times and the user
incremented to zero okay so this
basically shows how react implements
reusability of components moving on our
next topic is pure components now
another way to create class component is
by extending pure component from react a
pure component avoids unnecessary
re-renders now how does it do it it does
not implement the should component
update method now you learn about this
method a little later in the video now
this method enables re-rendering of
components to the dom but a pure
component on the other hand ensures a
shallow comparison of states and props
and checks if a re-render is actually
necessary only then does it render to
the dom a react component can be
considered pure if it renders the same
output for the same state and props so
let's take an example to explain pure
components so let's go back to our vs
code and create two component classes
one for a regular component and the
other for a pure component now using
this example i'll show you exactly how
pure component is more helpful okay so
let's create a
purecomponent.js file i say pureform.js
so here i'm going to use a snippet rpce
that is going to create a pure component
class let me get rid of this export and
here in my div tag i'll display the text
say i'm
the pure component all right now let's
go ahead and create a regular component
let me call it
regular component.js and here i'm going
to use the snippet rce and the message
that i want to display is
i'm
the regular component so to draw a
comparison between the regular component
and the pure component let's create a
parent component for the two so let me
create one here i'll call it parent
component.js and this is again going to
be a regular class component and here i
display the message i am the parent
component to change the state of the
component we're going to make use of a
constructor so let's use the snippet our
const and here let me create
name you can give anything and i say
simply learn now we make use of the
component did mount lifecycle method to
set a time interval now don't worry
about this we're going to learn about it
a little later in the video so moving
ahead i'm going to make use of the
method and say component
did mount and here i say set interval
the first argument is going to be an
arrow function and the second will be
the time interval and i'm going to be
setting it to 3 seconds now within the
arrow function i'll make use of the set
state function to set the state of my
property however i do not change the
name i keep it simply on itself moving
on let's import pure component and the
regular component into our parent
component and then pass name as a
property so to do that first import pure
comp
from your component and then i say
import
regular com from regular form.js and
here let's say regular comp name
equals this dot state dot
name and i say pure component name
equals this
dot state dot name now let's include the
property name in both our regular and
pure components so to do that let's just
say this dot
drop dot name
and here i again say this
dot prop dot name and finally let's
import parent component into our app.js
component so here i say import parent
com from okay and here let me define
parent.com
so now if you look at the browser we
have i'm the parent i'm regular
component simply learn and i'm the pure
component simply done we've got the
result as expected now to check if the
pure component is actually re-rendering
or not let's include simple console.log
statements so here i say clg snippet and
here i say
pure
component
render and in my regular component i do
the same thing i say console.log regular
component
render now let's do the same in our
parent component as well here i say
parent
component render all right so let's go
back to our browser
and inspect it in our console first the
parent component gets rendered then the
regular component and then the pure
component after that for every three
seconds only the parent component and
the regular component is rendered for
the same state and prop the pure
component is not re-rendered so in
conclusion pure components optimize
react codes and also improves
performance so coming to the last topic
component life cycle so basically
comprehend life cycle explains the
stages the component goes through the
entire life cycle of a component can be
divided into three parts we have
mounting updation and unmounting so the
first thing that gets invoked in the
life cycle is component will mount it is
invoked right before the initial
rendering occurs then we have the
rendering method now once a component is
inserted into the dom component did
mount gets invoked coming to the next
phase we have updation when a complaint
receives props component will receive
props gets invoked set state is called
when the state of the property changes
so every time there is a change react
decides whether the next component state
should trigger a re-render or not to do
that should component update method is
called component will update is invoked
right before re-rendering after
re-rendering component did update is
called that makes updates to the dom and
the last phase is unmounted component
will unmount method does all the
necessary cleanup and erases all the
allocated memory and cycles moving ahead
let's learn about another striking
feature of react.js called props props
short for properties allow the user to
pass arguments or data to components a
parent component can pass additional
information to its children using props
properties help make components more
dynamic props are passed to components
in the way similar to that of html track
attributes now we'll look at this a
little later in the video props in a
component are read only and cannot be
changed one thing to remember is that
props are sent by the parent to the
children components hence the children
components cannot make any changes to
these props now that we've learnt about
props in brief let's go ahead and create
our application using props if you're
new to this tutorial i suggest you go to
the react installation and react
components video on our channel so back
in my code editor that is vs code i've
opened a folder called react props
and now i'm going to create a component
a class component and i'll call it class
props dot js so let's create the class
component i give rce the snippet
and here i display a message saying an
h1 tag basically
all right
now let me get rid of export here and
import it in my app.js main component
here i say import
class props
all right now we define the class
component in our render method
let's say
all right
now if we go back to the browser you see
hello learners welcome to simply learn
now let's say we want to individually
welcome every student instead of
retyping the message for everybody we
can pass their names as props now let's
see how to do that now we pass the name
as a property from the main component
that is app.js to the child component
and render this onto the browser so
let's do that so here
while i'm defining my child component i
say name
i save it and here in my child component
instead of learners
i say i use the keyword this dot props
dot name
let me save it and if you look at the
browser we'll have hello learner one
welcome to simply learn now let's go
ahead and welcome learner 2 and learner
3 so i again say class props
name
equals
learner 2.
all right so if we save and look at the
browser we'll have all the three
learners displayed on the browser we can
also pass multiple props to the child
component now say for example we want to
welcome the student from a particular
place so we say welcome learner1 from
place x so i can here
define another property say place
and say place
similarly i can do it
for the rest two
say place y
now let's go back to our class props.js
component and here say hello
learner1
from
this dot props
dot
place let me save it and if you look at
the browser now we have hello learner1
from place x place y and place z we can
also display whatever we want between
the opening and closing tags when
invoking a component now this is
facilitated using props dot children
reserved keyword now let me explain to
you how it's done with an example here
let's split the self and closing tag
into
an opening and a closing tag and in
between them let me display a message
within the paragraph tag let me say
and in my
child component
after my h1 tag
let me use a paragraph tag and here
let's use the reserved keyword this dot
props dot children
so let's save it
and now if you look at the browser you
can here see the message displayed child
component so prop stop children can be
used when components do not know about
their children ahead of time this is
commonly seen in components like sidebar
and dialog that represent generic boxes
so let's go ahead and create a button
tag and check again
so here
i'll split it and add a button tag
and say click
and let's check our browser
here we go
we get the output as expected all right
we saw the usage of props for class
components similarly we can use it for
functional components so let's go ahead
and create a functional component let me
call it
i say import
react from
react
and then i say function
function props
and here i return
an h3 tag
i'll say this is
functional component
and i'll return another h3 tag
saying
hello learner
so let me save this
and let's export it
export
default
[Music]
function props
[Music]
and import it
in our app.js again
import
function proper
[Music]
function prop
and here in our render method let's
define it
let me call
function prop
name
let me give learner 4
and
place
place say a
let me close it
and back in our functional component
instead of learner
i say
props dot
name
let me save it
now if you look at our browser it gives
us an error it says props is not defined
so let's go back to our code editor and
pass props here
to our functional component also
let me define hello props.name
from
props dot place
let me enclose it within the div tag
here
[Music]
let me save it and now if you look at a
browser here we go we get the output as
expected let's begin and learn what
exactly is a state in react typically a
state is an object that stores the
values of properties belonging to a
component now these values can change
over a period of time either by a user
interactions or network changes and the
state helps facilitate this
functionality every time the state
changes react re-renders the component
to the browser the state is initialized
in the constructor a state can also
store multiple properties a method
called set state is used to update the
value of the state object now this
function performs a shallow merge on the
new and the previous state
conventionally a shallow merge ensures
that the previous state values are
overwritten by the new state values
moving on in our previous video we
learned about props and although props
and state dictate and control the
behavior of a component they have
significant differences so let's go
ahead and draw a comparison between the
two firstly props in a component are
used to pass data and event handlers to
its children while state on the other
hand is used to store the data that has
to be rendered on the web page props are
immutable once said by the parent they
cannot be changed state holds volatile
data and can be changed over time props
can be used in functional and class
components while state is restricted to
class components props are set by the
parent component while a state is
generally updated by event handlers now
that we've learnt all about state let's
go ahead and build an application to see
the working of state all right so in my
code editor that is vs code i've created
my application say state and here in my
source folder i have my app.js file now
here i'm going to get rid of all the
unnecessary code that i'm not going to
be using also i suggest you go through
the react installation on windows video
to help you get started with creating
your first application so let's create
our class component say class app
extends react dot component inside i
have a render method that returns an
html tag
let's display a message welcome
let's follow the jsx conventions and
enclose all the html tags within the div
tag so i say
div
class name equals app we also have to
import the app.css file import
app dot css
so we save it and if you look at the
browser we have welcome now let's
beautify our code to do that let's add
some styling so here in my app.js class
component i say styles
equals
and i say font
style and i set it to say bold and i say
color
say teal and here in my h1 tag i say
style equals this
dot
styles so let me save it and if you look
at the browser now we have welcome in
teal and it's bold now let's go ahead
and create a class component to
understand state so first i create a
folder and i call it components and
inside this folder i create a class
component and i call it new comp dot js
and i use the snippet rce to create the
class component to give you an insight
into what we're doing today we'll
display a message asking the user to
subscribe to simply learn once the user
clicks on the subscribe button we
instruct them to click on the bell icon
and finally we display a thank you
message now to do all of this we're
going to make use of state and as
mentioned earlier we initialize the
state object in a constructor so let's
use the snippet r const to create a
constructor now in the state object we
initialize a property let's call it
message and we display a message saying
subscribe to simply learn let's save it
and here in our render method let's say
class name
equals app and let's create an h3 tag
and within the tag i display the message
so i say
this
dot
state dot message let's save it and now
let's import it in our app.js component
so i'll get rid of export here and here
i say
import new com from components and
newcom and let's define it here and say
new so we save it and look at the
browser it says subscribe to simply
learn all right again to make our code
look more presentable let's add in
styles so i'll just copy the same styles
that i've added here and i'll paste them
here and instead of bold i make it
italic
and
i change the color to say
purple and again in my h3 tag
i define style and initialize it to this
dot styles so let me save it and now if
you look at the browser it's in italic
and it's in purple
okay so moving ahead let's create a
button that reads subscribe and once the
user clicks on it the button should read
subscribed and the message displayed
above should instruct the user to click
on the bell icon to do that let's first
create a button the message that i want
the button to read is subscribe however
this message gets changed once the user
clicks on the button so instead of
explicitly mentioning subscribe here i
create a prop i say sub and i say
subscribe here and back in my render
method i say this dot state
dot sub so let's save it and if you look
at the browser now you have a button
which displays a message subscribe now
once the user clicks on the button the
message displayed should change to click
on the bell icon to never miss an update
so let's create an event handler for
that so here
button on click i call another method
and let's call the method
button
change okay so this method should update
the state and change the message and sub
values to do that we make use of a set
state method now a state can be updated
in response to event handlers server
responses or prop changes now all the
updation can be done using the set state
method now this is the general syntax
used by the method we'll have a look at
this further in the demo now the set
state method conventionally enqueues all
the updates made to the component state
and instructs react to read under the
component and its children with the
updated state now let's go back to our
code editor and look at the working of
this method now here i define the arrow
function button change if you are not
familiar with arrow functions i suggest
you read up on them and this is the
general syntax and here i say this dot
set state and inside i change my message
to hit the bell icon to never
miss an update and my sub value changes
to
subscribed
let's save this and now if you look at
the browser when we click on the
subscribe button the message changes to
hit the bell icon to never miss an
update so moving ahead let's use a bell
icon so that the user can click on it
once he clicks on the image the image
changes and a thank you message appears
on the screen so for that i have two
images i have bell a and bell b so i
drag and drop both the images in my
components folder all right
now let's import these images into our
new com.js file
here i say import bell a
from
bell a dot
png and again i say import bell b from
bell b
dot png all right let me save it to
display the image on the screen we make
use of the image tag now this tag has
two attributes one is the source
attribute that specifies the url and the
other is the alt attribute that
specifies an alternate text for the
image so here in my component i say i
make use of a paragraph tag that will
help display the image in the next line
and then i use the image tag now since
my image changes once it's clicked i
have to define a property and pass the
event handler click that will update the
image so here
before specifying the source let's go
back to our state and define another
property
that is image url and let's set it to
bell a since that is the image that i
want to display first let me save it in
here in my image tag i say source
equals
this dot state
dot image url and then we have the alt
tag and i do not want to display any
message so i leave it as it is now let's
save it and if you look at the browser
we have a bell displayed however now
let's change the dimensions of the bell
i do not want such a huge bell so back
in my vs code i define style
with width say 30 pixels
and a height with again 30 pixels let me
save this and now if you look at the
browser we have a smaller icon so once
the user clicks on this image the emit
changes and the message displayed here
gets updated to do that we'll have to
define an event so let's go back to our
vs code and here in my image tag let's
say on click i define a method say this
dot
image change and now we define this
method here i see image change i make
use of an arrow function again
and again i use the set state method i
update the image so i say image url is
now set to bell
b and the message
is updated to thank you
happy learning
so let's save this now and if we look at
the browser we see the image and once
clicked on it the image gets updated and
the message changes so finally let me
refresh the browser once and show the
full execution let me refresh following
the instructions let's click on the
subscribe button and now it says hit the
bell icon and once i do that the image
updates and the message changes this
video on react.js helps you build two
fun applications using the library
as you all know react is a widely used
javascript library to build user
interfaces for applications
this video will make you realize why it
is adopted so widely
so first we'll build a calculator app
and then we'll move on to building a
spotify clone this time we're going to
introduce you another very interesting
project using this javascript html css
so called calculator application so
let's get started let me try to delete
first those files which we really do not
need it now
uh
we delete this all yeah now i'll be
creating a new folder now and give the
name called
calculator app
and in this calculator app once again we
need some new files which is called
index
dot html
and we also need one more that is called
app.css
and another one that is called app.js
so these three files required now first
of all i would start with
index.html5 where we'll be creating a
template of my code
now
let me go and create this template and
here
i have a god body with me
let's start with the
first
tag here that is called h1
and this h1 we are giving the name
called calculator
calculator so that will be my h1 heading
after that we'll start working with the
div tag
now within this div
i would have to create lot many classes
i may not have lot many css classes but
we can give some classes here so we can
say class equal to
container
okay so within this div tag we're going
to create a table now because i want to
organize it
so i'm starting with the table within
this table
tr tag
and within this tr tag i need a td
now in this td i need few things call
call
spam
equal to three
another value
and here
i want to offer the text box
input type equal to
text
okay input to text id equal to give the
name called result
that will be the final outcome while
pressing all the different buttons id
equal to result and
class
equal
to screen remember i haven't created
those css classes but but we're giving
some names but later on we can utilize
it while creating those css classes
table data is getting closed let's get
started with another td
now insert this td we need another text
box
input type equal to
text
and
here in this input text sorry i would
like to better say button because i'll
be having
buttons
okay
input i'm equal to
button
value
equal to
c
and
on click
equal to i may not have any function
right now but yes i can create
a function but let me give some domain
name here
i'm saying clear
screen
okay so that will be the function will
get called
and after that class
equal to
clear yeah so this is my button tag
after this the td tag is getting closed
after the td tag the table row is also
getting closed
after the table row
which is getting close we're going to
start working with another table row
okay and in this table row i'm going to
create one more td
so let's go ahead and create
another td here
and inside this td i'll be having
another button we get created
so i'll just say
this is another button now input equal
to button value equal to
one on click equal to i'll be calling
another function called display
okay and inside this we're giving the
value call one
okay and class equal to member
class equal to
number
and here after that td tag is getting
closed
okay now you have to start another td
tag here
okay like that you have to keep on
creating the multiple buttons so let me
copy
and paste another table data
now here
again value equal to 2 on click product
display
give the value call 2
and class equal to what
number
like that i'll keep on creating multiple
buttons but first check how it actually
looks like it
now i can see the buttons like in c one
two three
but yes i'm gonna create few more
buttons one after another
okay so i'll go here
and create a few more buttons so this is
where the table data is getting closed
okay i'll copy this
and paste it again
i have to create
the button
like in three four something like that
so after this two we're giving the value
called three
yeah
i'll get the value called three
so val equal to two
equal to three display three
and then afterwards
just giving the value call
forward slash
and here also we're gonna keep the value
forward slash
and here class is equal to
operator
operator after that
you have to do the valid con four
and then followed by five six seven
so here we give four
four
five
five
six
six
after six we're giving call minus
okay once again it will be what type of
operator
operator
okay after this minus we'll be talking
about call 7
then we have to have 8
okay 9.
okay after that we're giving call plus
and
display
plus plus equal to operator
operator okay so here
you can see the table data is getting
closed and here the table is also
getting closed and after this table row
we can start working with
another table row here
and
after this table row we can start
working with again
td let me have this
again
inside this i'll be giving the option
called decimal which is valid equal to
dot and here we get the value called
decimal
decimal
okay
now display zero
so after giving this dot to basically
take what the value
zero which we haven't put now
we'll be talking about value called zero
so here
the decimal value we have given it td is
getting close let me have another one
zero zero
so like that we have to keep this now
after that
we'll be once again
taking this and this time rather than
giving this zero
we'll be using this call as a button
and value equal to
equal
or click equal to
solve
okay and then this song will not be
passing anything
it like a normal function
and plus equal to equal
okay
so
table data is getting closed
so we will be using another table data
now
so here it will be the button only
okay we will be using
value equal to
multiplication
display
plastic and here we'll be using operator
okay
so table data is getting close table is
getting close table is also getting
closed here
okay so your dev tag is also getting
closed here
okay that's it
okay so that's the only thing which we
wanted to make let me try to refresh and
check
awesome
so we have got uh
all those
necessary calculator behavior
which we wanted to
reveal
okay now our next statement will be once
we're giving this c then we have a call
of one two three
and then forward slash
followed by
four five six will come down
okay so let me check whether we have
used six or not
okay so we haven't used six
so let me check here
four five six
so let me go back here
four five six let me copy this
and paste it later on
before
minus
six equal to
number
okay so we're almost set now
so we are having this uh
look and feel
in this way giving one two three four
five six
and after this we have a call minus and
then plus related behavior so we are all
set now and after that we'll be
basically applying the css as well as
the javascript look towards my code okay
thank you
well everybody we are all good to go now
but i just want to first check whether
my
uh this outlook is looking properly or
not see what my expectation is after one
two three forward slash i really want to
bring four five six to the next
and then seven eight nine and again
forward still but i can think this is
absolutely unorganized
so after this when we say
this uh forward slash which we have used
after hyphen
okay your td is getting closed here
okay so here the tr i also want to close
here
okay and after this tr i also want to
start
another tr here
okay so that i can put them into the
another level now
so under this tr i can use this dt now
so after this minus
after four five six
minus
once again i would like to start
another table over here
okay so that it let's go to the next row
so here
after td
we're closing this dr
and starting
another tier
okay we're starting another tier after
that we talk about 789
okay plus
see here talking about 789 plus here the
table is getting close and it is
starting right now like this
see that looks better now
okay but still few more things which i
would like to make it even more
organized but that's not a problem we
will do it later on
okay because you can see eight is
missing right now
so here
seven
we copy this
equal to eight
eight
yeah that looks better now so now they
are basically completely organized
so the moment i expect my application so
we have a call
dot here then zero then equal to and
then multiplication
okay so it looks
better now
now i just would like to perform
the overall look and feel
so i need to go ahead and use what css
because without css i really can't
utilize this in a proper way so i have
to start working with a css friend now
in css front how to start first we will
go back to my code and here in my css
we'll start working with
font family but before font family i
would like to start with the body part
now
body
background color i'm using called t
that looks nice
okay so
i will be using this app.css
in my html to see the look how it has
been appeared right now
so in my index.html file
on the top under my head section
link
style sheet
okay now see it looks better now
going forward
in my css
we want to use
some h1 color tool so here
we would like to use h1
texture line
center
color
white
margin top
margin top we'd like to use 50 pixels
this is for h1 let's check
perfect so it is now coming in between
next statement will be called screen so
we say
screen
so in this screen we use the background
color
diagram color gray
and after that border
sorry
border solid
black and two pixels
after that color
white
font size
medium
next width
we're using this
100
then we talk about cursor
we would like to say 10 pixels
and then
margin
save auto
then margin bottom
that i'll be using 10 pixels
so in the proper alignment
okay
look
that's how exactly we want that's for a
screen where the exact outcome will be
visible to me and rest of the details
we'll be showing you one by one and now
we'll be talking about call input
okay
input
type
i say
background color
change to what
right or else i can say
let's walk
okay
and
when the button is active
what i want
let me copy
and put a little button and here i say
active
and this color should be orange red
like this
you can see now how it is basically
looking like it
okay active the color will be like this
okay i'll be talking about color
operators
operator should behave different so i'm
saying dot
operator in this operator we are saying
background color
background color orange
okay then padding
i want five pixels
okay then i want color
that should be black
after this i'm using call border
sorry
that border
i'm using this called solid
and then black
and
after this bit
i'm using 100
then height
height is 40 pixels
then cursor
it has to be pointed
okay that's it let's check
perfect so they shall turn back to what
to your
orange color
and uh
you can see the moment you take
microsoft turns to white
perfect and now those were type number i
also want to change them
so for number
for number i want to say the same option
i want 5 pixels
then i need height
of type 40 pixels
then i say color
it looks
and
awesome so they looks nice
now we left a few
other type of options i can dot and
equal to
okay that i'm talking about called
decimal for decimal i need to have a
different options with me
okay so
let me try to copy this
paste it and i
light blue
padding 5 pixels color black border
solid
okay black two pixels with hundred
percent height forty pixels five and
cursor
pointer
perfect
okay looks nice but i have changed the
color
now
i talk about
clear
okay
now come back
and say
clear
okay in this color
background color is i'm changed to light
salmon
light salmon
padding 5 pixels color black
border same width 100
height 40 pixels
fine so cursor
pointer
file margin
auto and margin bottom
let's check
perfect not looks beautiful
okay
now
here after giving these details we're
talking about called equal part dot
equal
so for dot equal also i'm just copying
the same
so you recall
background color id color
just change to
lightly
light green
and
after this
since it is an equal so we say padding
five pixels is okay color black fine
border fine with hundred percent high 40
pixels
color and cursor pointers just i don't
need to
it's for dot equal and i want
for container
container
in this container width i want 40
percent
red 40 percent background color white
okay
now here
writing is 15 pixels
so display block
so first of all width
display block
which we're taking margin
okay in merchandising to pixels
okay
now align cells
go to
center
okay border radius
border radius let's just say 10 pixels
okay now using box shadow
box shadow 5 pixels
black
and padding
so these are details i have it
okay
we have it
background color we are taking it now
align cell
display block border radius padding
and then
writing 15 pixels we have given
i don't need to give it again
margin
okay fine
box shadow let's try
awesome so it's looking beautiful now
okay so this is where exactly my
application
works like that
and table when we talk about
everything with
100
okay
that's it
super
so it's now giving me the proper look of
how
my application should be here i can just
see about the container what we have
done
with 40 we're taking background color
let's bring it below
then align self
display block
okay margin
okay
and border radius
and
fine so i think we're all good now
so
that's it so we'll try and implement the
javascript part well everyone so our css
file is ready
our html is ready it's time to just uh
go ahead and talk about my
final portion that is called gs part
where i want to basically perform some
calculators
now here i just say function
display
function display which takes
val as in parameter and say
document dot
get element by id
here i'm saying
result
okay dot
value
okay
plus
equal to
whatever we are adding it just basically
try to apply
calculation on the top of that
okay there is a function
after that we have another functions
available here called function solve
here in the solve
we just use the value called let x equal
to
document dot create element by id
result
okay
dot value sorry
dot
value
okay and say connect
y
equal to
perform the calculations for the using
one function called
eval
and type
access and parameter
now the next statement will be again
document dot
get administrator
result
dot
value equal to
y okay
now
later on
i'll try to use another function here
function
clear
screen and here we say
document.
get it in my id
here we say
result
dot
value
equal to
like that
so clear screen
song
and
display
three functions are associated with me
and these three functions are the part
of this javascript file which i'll be
calling it
at the end before
the water tag get closed so here
script
i will say plus
six
equal to eight absolutely i say c is
clear the screen
six
divided by
two
equal to 3 awesome so friends your
calculator application is ready
congratulations to all so it is a very
simplest form which we have developed
this is your html which is a template
for you this is the css which is your
complete
the area of like how the look and feel
will look like in of this template
beautification and here last year for gs
which is smaller logic but really
meaningful
okay if getting your learning started is
half the battle what if you could do
that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
let's start with uh creating a simple
demo on react.js and we are going to
create a simple application
that will connect to an online music
streaming service called spotify and we
will call our application music app so
let's get started the first step is to
first get the node.js platform and
server installed to do that let me go to
google and let's just type node.js
and here is the website
nodejs.org there are two versions
available the lts which is the stable
version and the current we'll prefer the
stable so we'll click on that and you
can see we have an option which is
called save file the moment this file is
saved to the disk we just need to double
click on it and keep clicking on the
next button to get it installed on our
system and we also have a documentation
available here so which explains most of
the features of the node platform and
there are binaries available for
different os's mac windows etc so you
can select the right witness 32-bit
64-bit and the right os
and then go ahead and download the
specific
version that suits
your platform
and you can see here that there are
different there are also help files
available that will allow you to go
through the installation documents for
node.js installation on linux etc so to
start with uh i'm opening up the command
prompt and here is where we are going to
call the node package manager using the
node package manager which is
pre-installed with your standard node.js
installation we will initialize our
react application so we would say react
dash app and
we want to now go and create an
application called music app in this
folder so as a prerequisite for the demo
all we need to do is install node.js
from node.js.org the official website
just download it and install it and
that's when you open the command prompt
you fire npm which stands for node
package manager init for initialize
react dash app is a standard keyword to
initialize and create a skeletal
structure of a react.js application and
the name of the app is music app so
we'll hit enter we'll give this some
time and you can see it's
started downloading the core
react gs libraries and it is attempting
to create uh
our application so it's installing all
the prerequisite packages and scripts
that are required initialize and create
a new react.js application called music
app now once this application is created
all we would require is an online editor
so you could use an offline or an
on-premise editor as well so any editor
of your choice it could be atom or
sublime text or webstorm and uh for this
demo uh we're going to use visual studio
code which is a
free editor available by microsoft and
you can just google for visual studio
code again this is not visual studio
professional edition etc that we use for
building our c-sharp or mbc-based
applications this is a lightweight
editor for building javascript based
footstep full applications so so while
this installs let's go and take a look
at uh visual studio code so this is the
visual studio code editor and this is
the editor that we've
installed directly downloaded from
visualstudiocode.com and installed it
and all we need to do is open up this
folder that would be created with all
the prerequisite files in it we just say
file open folder and we would open that
folder within our visual studio code
editor so we'll give it a while until
that application gets generated and once
it's created uh we will again implement
the component based design and
architecture
and the data flow between the components
and we also look at connecting to a live
data source which is a json set of
characters that we would consume which
is a restful service the set of music
tracks
exposed as a restful api endpoint by
spotify which is a premium streaming
service we will connect to that and we
will look at uh accessing some of the
music tracks on that website okay so
we've got uh the application created
here so let's minimize this and
we'll open up our editor all we've got
to say is file and open folder and
let me go to the react.js demo folder so
this is the music app that got created
and that's exactly what we're going to
open up here so we'll navigate to
that folder it's called music app we'll
select it
and have it opened in our application so
you can see here we've got a node
modules uh folder this has all of the
pre-installed packages that make up the
react.js library we've got a folder
called public which will have the
index.html file that's the root file
that will launch so this is the single
page application that we typically
create
in react you have a single page
which on which we're going to load
multiple components so that's the
index.html and then we could go and
create
a folder structure
currently if i open the source folder we
can see a single app.js file and that
basically is
the file that has uh the source code in
javascript for a single component which
uh we are interested in adding on to our
page as of now so we just have one
component which is the default root
component that's the app component and
it has its corresponding css file
and then we've got
the a public folder with the index.html
file which is going to be
the root html file that launches
when we run our application so let's uh
go right up here and let's add
a link to an additional file so i'm
going to link to another style sheet
okay so we say relationship is equal to
stylesheet and the type is going to be
text
and css
and
we will reference a file called
reset
dot css and this is a file that we look
at
adding up later on it doesn't exist at
this point in time so we will connect
this and that's purely for styling
purposes
so that we can have
all of our css styles defined there next
thing i'll right click on the public
folder we'll create a new file we'll
name this file as reset dot css so
that's going to be the css file that
will have all of the css
styling that we're going to apply and
i'm going to use a ready code snippet uh
for the css code so let me just uh okay
so i'll all i'll do is uh i'll just go
and pick up
a ready css file that i can just go and
use if you look here i have a set of
css files that are created that we're
just going to use
within our application and
and that will avoid us spending a lot of
time on the styling so that we can focus
on our core concepts
which is actually learning how component
based architecture works and how do we
set up components and have data
communication between them in react so
here is a file called
reset.css
let me just fire up
notepad and i'll just open up this file
copy up the text here and i'm going to
just paste it within
my reset.css and if you look at the code
very simple it's all about styling so
we've got
article aside etc all html5 tags set up
as display block so they take up the
entire width of the page we've got some
padding margin and font size etc defined
we've removed list styling for the
unordered and ordered list specifying
the line height for the body tag so
basically uh just styling up tables and
so nothing nothing to do with react here
it's just about simple
css that we've added up and now we need
to actually go in and dive into create
creation of the components that we need
so let's right click on the source
folder so i'll select the source folder
we'll right click there and that's where
we're going to create a new folder which
is called components okay so this is the
components folder now that's going to
hold
all of the components within it within
the components folder let me create
another new folder and i'm going to call
it app and this is exactly how we are
expected to structure all of the code
that we have now i already have a css
and app.js which are the root components
that were added by default and all i'm
going to do is i'm going to move them
within this folder called app okay so
there's a proper segregation of
responsibility and
all of the code that
deals with a particular component is all
added into respective folders and this
really improves the maintainability of
the application
going forward now we need some images
and i'm just going to make use of some
set of images that i've downloaded from
the web and
here are the set of images that i have
so i'm just going to copy all of them
and we'll come to our music app and
we'll go into the components and app
folder and that's where we're going to
add all of the files and you've seen all
of those image files getting added so
these are just icons and images we're
going to use for our music tracks inside
our application now uh let's move to the
app.css file and uh
this is where we've actually got uh
so the app.css file is the file that's
going to style up
the
all of the style rules that we've added
into the root app component and
this is what we'll have to revamp so
i'll just get rid of this code and
we'll probably add something for the
body tag the html tag and the root
element let me say hash root and let's
set the height to a hundred percent
coming to all of the html across the
page we'll give it a font size of 10
pixels
and
the h1 elements
let me give it a padding of
0.77 and 0 let's set
a background color give it a background
color and just select
some random color here that can be
applied then we'll set up the text
alignment which is going to be the
center of the page we'll set up the font
family the font family is
and this is part of
sans serif what else do we add let's add
up the font size
1.88 and also the color so again uh
these are standard uh html and css
elements so uh nothing really that
has to be done uh that is specific to
react here so again we are bringing in
the highlight class so there is a class
called highlight that we will create
later in the
html view of this component and we'll
set this to a red rgb component so
combination of 46 113 and 238 okay so
that's uh pretty much done let's move on
and also add up for the anchor tag let's
add up some text decoration and set it
to none so that the anchor tags don't
come up with those underlines and of
course we'll provide a color of hash
okay so a white color there now coming
to the h2 element for the h2 element
let's have font family and again i'm
going to use
so i'm going to use
the font family that we defined here
bracket and we change this to probably
1.5
okay now coming to the app tag uh let me
just save this and create a copy of it
uh there was some content that
i did delete and
i can simply go and make use of it so
i've just undone all of the deletion so
this is uh something that i can't
if i can use something i can just
probably use it from the tag below so
let me start with a height here and
let's say the height of the header is
hundred percent of the app sorry not
header padding 0 17
10
17
the background and i'm going to change
that to background url so the background
url or let's say the background image
will have a url property okay and that
url is going to be dot slash
pg1 dot jpeg so that's the image that
we've added some in the previous step
let's also add
background size so we'll add background
size and set it to cover i also need
a background position
to center let's have background repeat
which is set to
no repeat so that we don't have the
image
in a grid format
and then i would need this bit of it
let's take up the font family we'll
maintain the same font family let's use
font weight the font weight is going to
be 500 and the color is going to be hash
so that's a white color then we come to
dot app dot playlist so that's going to
be
another class that we are going to use
dot but app dash playlist is what we
we're going to name it and
let me say that the display should be
flex
flexible display and we will justify the
content to leave spaces
in between all right so that finishes
that bit and now uh
let's write up a media query for the
responsiveness of this page so this is
media for only screen and
max width is going to be one zero two
zero pixels okay and the class name that
we'll provide later is obviously app
playlist so for this screen size we
would align all the items
to the center and we change the flex
direction okay so we seem to be good
with
the css for the app as of now and that's
the app.css
that we created let me save everything
okay let's check
for any kind of
additional so all three of errors no
errors now things are good in the app
css and it's time to move to the next
step of building this application uh now
we'll have to go and add up
the code for uh the app.js file so let's
dive into the app.js file uh and this is
where
we will actually need to go and add
all of the code that is required for the
app component so all the code that's
relevant to
the app component we are going to add up
inside this specific component itself
which is going to be obviously the
app.js file so we have skeletal code
which is import importing the react
library and
let me get rid of the basic sample logo
we'll have app.css that's getting
imported here
besides that lot of other files that
we'll have to get in so uh let me import
playlist and this is these are the
components that we'll create
as we go forward and
we're going to get this from the
playlist folder
and the component the file is going to
be called playlist so we'll add that
then we'll have to go and also import
search bar so what we're basically doing
is we're going to split this app into
different components there's going to be
one component that manages the playlist
of all the tracks
one component will
act as the search bar so that's the
search bar component that we're going to
add so searching for tracks will be
managed by this we'll have another
component that we create that will get
imported into the root app component
which is a search results so this is
going to display the record set with the
set of results as an outcome of the
search criteria so search results slash
search results and finally we'll go and
import spotify that's the spotify
service
from so we'll create a utility folder
which will hold
the code that connects us to spotify so
that's what we are adding up next so all
of the imports are done one component
that manages the search bar so that's
search bar search results let me correct
the spellings there that search results
that spotify and playlist so that's done
now let's move on to the class that
we're going to create here so let's
create a class app that goes and extends
react dot component so that's going to
be a react.js component so that's a
constructor we discussed about props or
properties and state management and
that's what we are implementing we are
using the super keyword as a best
practice so that all the properties are
initialized in the constructor and also
we pass the values up the chain to the
superclass which is the root component
class now we're going to initialize
a variable called state that's going to
manage the state and we are interested
in tracking our search results so we'll
have multiple results so we'll store
that as an array the playlist would have
different names so we'll just call ours
new playlist that's the default name and
we will also store a list of tracks
which is going to be playlist
tracks so playlist tracks is going to be
a list of tracks and let's close
this block okay and this two is going to
be initialized within the constructor so
we'll add it here and now we need to do
the binding we discussed uh data binding
so let's look at
creating a search variable which will
hold
this dot
search dot bind and bind to the context
of this very class so we are passing
this pointer then we'll create
another variable called add track which
to this dot add track dot bind and all
this functionality is what we're going
to add going forward so right now we're
just setting up the bindings then we'll
have capability to remove a track so
we'll say remove track so remove track
equal to this dot
remove track dot pint and
let's fix that so and all of these two
is going to be initialized as part of
the constructor so that's where we're
going to add it then we need to update
update the playlist name so we need
functionality that will help us to
update the name of the playlist so
functionally that helps us to update the
playlist name so this dot update
playlist
name is equal to this dot
update playlist name dot bind and this
is the pointer that we'll pass i need to
save the playlist so this dot
save playlist
equal to this dot save playlist dot find
and pass this and then i would also need
to remove the track that has been
searched for from the playlist so remove
track search go to this dot
okay remove track search and
dot find and finally one last function
that
executes
all of these which probably will bind to
bind to this context so all the
declarations are done in the constructor
now we need to provide the definitions
for all the methods that we actually
have added here so let me select this
tab inside and let's start with the
search function so we define the search
first it takes
some variable value that it searches on
and then i'm going to say spotify dot
search i'm going to search for term dot
then and that's an observable so the
moment it the search returns a value
it's going to call this
callback function and that's when we
want to set the state and we're going to
set the state for search results to
whatever is passed by the system so the
search results are going to be returned
as a callback and that's what we store
as an updated state now coming to the
add track method so let's scroll up and
we'll say add track and this will take
the track to be added let's declare a
temporary variable called tracks equal
to this dot the current state of all the
tracks that are there in the playlist
now if track start find i'm going to
call the find method so if we are able
to find which means that the track is
already there in the playlist then we
would not want to add it if it's not
there in the playlist that's when we
would want to go and add it the triple
equal to is an equality operator that
will check for both a watch value match
and a match on the data type as well
okay so if the track is uh already saved
to nothing if the track is not safe just
track the track id because that is the
track that will uh have to be added if
it's not if it's already there then just
return if it's not there then we've got
to go to this variable called tracks
we'll use the javascript method called
push and we will push the current track
into this tracks
array and then update the state so we
want to set the state of the playlist
tracks and this is how
your state management that we discussed
in detail is actually being practically
implemented here okay so the track has
been added now let's talk about the
remove track so that's the remove track
function and that's the track that we
want to remove so let's let tracks equal
to this dot state dot playlist tracks
those the set of current tracks that we
have and
let track search another temporary
variable equal to this dot the current
state of the search results then let's
take the tracks array equal to track
start filter so filter is of javascript
function that will again allow you to
remove a certain value create a
temporary variable called current track
use the lambda operator and if the
current track dot id is
not equal to the track dot id which
means this particular track is not there
in the list
okay so you need to remove that and
again i have a method called as unshift
which will actually get rid of the track
in the array and then we've got to so
we'll search whether that
track is existing in the tracks array if
it is then we simply want to remove it
if not we do nothing so we set the state
we need to update the state of the
playlist because the track has been
removed so the playlist tracks will have
to be updated with this tracks array
okay then we go for remove track search
that's the next method that also will
take a track as a parameter okay here we
are going to say let tracks which is
another temporary variable we'll give it
this current state of
search results and then we are going to
say tracks equal to tracks dot filter
current track current track dot id not p
equal to the track dot id and then this
is where we would want to say this dot
set
state
and we'll pick up search results
and let's go and assign that to track so
that's the updated
set of tracks after making that change
let's remove this and correct it okay so
that's fine so the remove track
is now the remove track and the remove
track search is now in place let's add
the do these functions which actually
again takes track as a parameter and
here we'll say this dot add track okay
so it adds the track and then it removes
the track from the search criteria so
the search component which is managing
searching of the tracks it will go and
remove it from there after adding the
new track so that's a combined
operation we want to execute then i've
got update playlist name which will take
the name of the track to update and this
dot set state the playlist
name is what we need to update with the
name that is passed to this function
then we've got to save playlists so
here we let me create a constant
variable constants are variables whose
values will not frequently change we'll
take all the track uris dot state dot
playlist tracks
will be dot map create a temporary
variable called track track dot url so
we actually want to go and uh now save
this on uh spotify so that's the reason
we'll access
spotify's safe playlist method this dot
state dot playlist name comma track uris
and if that is successful we then go
into a callback so that's the callback
anonymous function where we're going to
say this dot
set date and the playlist
name that we want to create on spotify
will be called new playlist so that's
the custom
name that i want to provide and the
playlist tracks
define that this closes here
okay so that's for the update on
spotify
now here is where
the render method is going to return the
html now this html is the view
and react simplifies this by having the
javascript and the html in the same
file so you can actually go and access
the variables you've declared in the
script directly in your html view
and synchronize and bind the data
together so it helps
from a maintainability perspective so
even though everything is in the same
file it's well classified and
differentiated into different code
blocks so we'll add the anchor tag and
we'd say href is http localhost so
that's the default server port on which
this application will run okay and we
want to give it a custom url name of
musical file so the h1 terminates will
then say div class name equal to app
within that this is how we're going to
inject our search bar that's going to be
the search bar component injected here
and on search so that's the custom event
we will call a method called search so
on search we just call we bind to a
method called this dot search then we'll
open up another div here we'll have
class name equal to app dash playlist
and if you remember that's exactly the
css
class name that we referred to in the
css file
we have another component called search
results
that we're going to inject here
and
that's going to be search results here
search results will be equal to this dot
state dot search results so that's how
we can actually go and bind so that's
simple data binding the component is
going to be displayed with the data
bound and if somebody says add if if i
click on the add button for search
results
do these so it will add that new track
to the playlist by calling binding to
the 2ds function and it will remove it
from the search results text box then we
have another component called playlist
and here the playlist tracks
will be bound to this dot state dot
playlist tracks okay so on the top if
you look here we started with defining
all the function declarations in the
constructor then we provided the
function definitions okay that's how and
this that we passed refers to the
context of the current
component itself so whatever you put
into the app component or into the
respective component those values will
be then passed out here to these
individual functions okay so that's with
the playlist couple of things we'll have
to do is if somebody changes the name of
the track so on name change is going to
be another custom event where we have to
call this dot update playlist name and
we also have remove functionality so to
remove a track we would say equal to
this dot remove track on save equal to
this dot
save playlist okay so that's done and we
close this so we seem to be pretty much
uh on track the export
app will make this all of these
functions accessible across other
components it's very similar to the
public access specifiers etcetera that
you provide
in other programming languages so that's
done we've created our app component now
let's create another folder under
components and we've got to define all
our various components here this folder
is going to be
for the search bar so we'll name it
search bar we'll add two files within it
the search bar dot css okay and another
file that we'll need here is
search bar
dot js
so that's in terms of the search bar
let's start with the css file so we'll
start with first styling search bar we
will say that the display should be flex
flex direction should be column we want
all the items to be aligned at the
center so that's align item center then
we'll add up padding so padding top
is going to be
6.94 rpm and
margin bottom is going to be
6.33 rem all right now let's add up for
the search bar so that's search bar
we'll add
for the input element we want the width
to be 287 pixels the padding to be 0.88
0 the border
should be one pixel solid white the
border radius
will give a slight rounded edge uh to
give a web 3.0 look and feel so we'll
set up the border radius then we've got
uh margin bottom so we've got a bottom
margin that we want to add up then we
have color so let's add up the color c3f
so that's the color black then let's add
text alignment of center and let's add
up a font size of one rem okay so that's
how we've set this up let's add
the search bar input is going to be
so if someone focuses so focus is the
got focus so if someone clicks inside so
the end user goes and clicks inside the
text box
we change the outline to none okay and
so for the search bar we are interested
uh on input and if the input is
focused so that's the event that we are
looking for and then we would have a
button called search button so on the
search button the cursor will set it to
pointer so that's the cursor pointer the
width we set it to 8.11
rem the padding we are going to set up
to
0.77 rem and 0 the border radius
we'll set it to 54 pixels so we get a
slightly uh well defined search button
with a nice little border let's also add
background color hash one db 954
that gives me a color then i've got
my text alignment let's set that to
center then we've got a font family
let's set up the font family to the same
standard font 80
and it's a part of the sans serif family
then we'll set up the font size
to
three 0.833 rem correct this
uh and finally
we will need
transition so all of these are basic uh
css properties so that will add a slight
uh transitional effect with a delay of
that many milliseconds
so transition background color we've
provided what else let me scroll up uh
let's also provide a border here so
we'll remove in fact let's remove the
border we we would not want a border on
the button that would look odd so i'll
get rid of the border and color we'll
specify as per our standard color that
we've been using okay so that's the
color we've specified and then i've got
font weight of 500. finally we'll take
uh the search button and on the search
button we will register for the hover
event so if someone takes their mouse
over the button that's the over the
event in that case if we hover around
the button we would want
the background
color to change so it will appear to
have a slight little glow there a mouse
pointer moves over the button okay so
that's the opacity and
the rgb combination so that completes uh
the css file for the search bar and we
obviously now need to go and
get the code in for
our search bar component and that's
exactly what we are going to do next so
let's start with setting up the code for
the search file first thing let's go and
import
react from
react
next thing we would want to do is import
the search bar dot
css file then we define a class
called search bar which extends
react dot component we define our
constructor and we go and
pass these parameters to the base class
we also define
the state we just need one variable here
which is
the term to search for in the search bar
and then let's say this dot
will define a function called handle
term change which is going to be equal
to this dot handle handle term change
dot
find so that's going to be the first
function then a function that will do
the searching for us
which is this dot search so that's the
search function and we'll have it bind
to this
then we've got this dot
handle enter so the moment we enter into
that search text box
handle enter dot find this
so the functions are ready now let's go
for the first one which is handle term
change
we'll pass it a system defined keyword
of event this dot
set state
and for the term
we will use the event keyword we will
get the value that is there inside that
text box the moment the search term the
user has entered changes so the search
criteria changes we trap the updated
value then in the search function we
will update the local property props dot
on
search
okay so we'll access the on search and
pass it the updated term and then we got
the handle enter on which
uh we're also going to pass the system
define event keyword so if there's any
data flowing along with the event we are
interested in it in this case the data
is the key code that the user is
pressing and if it is 13 that indicates
uh that's the ascii key code for the
enter button so if the enter is hit then
the user is completed entering the
search criteria and we need to start
searching and that's where we write our
render method that's going to render the
html view and we return the complete
view here so that's the view now that we
want to return let's say tiff class name
equal to search bar then on the input
text box we will use placeholder equal
to enter song album
or artist that you want to search for on
change
on the on change event the moment the
term changes we connect that to handle
term change we already have an
function that manages that and the
moment
keys are pressed and released so on key
up is where we would want to connect to
this dot handle enter okay and this is
place bracket that i have to put up here
so in the render function
we're going to return a value i
shouldn't forget to export the search
bar okay so that's
what i want to export so we've exported
that okay so at the end of this
what we've done is we've written a
render method we've written our div tag
here is where we'll go and close
the div tag we've added an input and
here is where i'm going to add a button
provide a class name called search
button and the moment the end user
clicks on the button we're going to
connect it to this dot
search and we close
the button back within the button tag
search so that
completes the
render function so in the render
function again let's run through all of
what we've written we started with
extending react.component we then added
a constructor passing props to the super
class constructor we created
state we set it to a value of
term and null so the state currently we
defined as term then we said handle term
changes search and handle enter should
be functions that we want to add then
handle term changes
we defined search we defined and handle
enter we've also defined then we used
render render we said is going to return
to us
the html that we've specified okay we
dumped all the html that we want this
component to return to us
so on change and on key up are
two functions that
or two events that we connected to where
we called handle term change and handle
enter then we added a button where we
registered for the click event and
connected it to this dot search so all
the three functions
that we
had actually written
so two things we've completed now uh in
the app class
okay if you look at the app class we've
actually defined a set of functions here
that deal with the playlist and adding
applications etc adding tracks removing
tracks
then we've created
the search bar okay so we saw that the
search bar also we have specified a set
of functions
and all the functions that we defined we
have taken care to structure every
component separately so the search
component is doing something completely
different which is managing the search
bar we have the core the root app
component in which we have imported all
of the other set of javascript classes
uh that we are creating uh and that's
how the entire application is now
structured so and that's the core uh
concept when you're working with react
where you would actually have every
separate
block of
code or every separate functionality
handled in a different component
altogether so we've completed the search
bar component as well so two components
done and two components uh good to go so
we've got to start up on the next set of
components that we will need to build
and the next component is the track
component that will manage individual
tracks so a new folder a new file called
track.css
and
track.js
so that's going to manage
the tracks for us
so let's start with dot track we would
say display is flex
align items
center border bottom one pixel solid rgb
256
256
256 0.8 that's the opacity then let's
come to track action so we'll use all of
these classes
when we write up the html view we'll add
a padding here of 0.5 we'll set up a
font size
of 1.05
set up a transition color of 0.25
s
order of 0 pixel and
a background color of rgb a
0 0 0 0 color ash so that's the color
that we continue to use then we bring in
track another class track action and if
we hover over this class we want
the gb values
change to 265 to 265
265 5 is the last parameter so that's
the hover
then we have track information so track
information is the next class that we're
dealing with we'll add the flex
parameter first
display flex
and
then flex
direction
is going to be column let's have justify
content set up as
center and let's have height as
180 pixel so that's uh track information
let's have another track information and
the h3 tags nested inside that for all
the h3 tags nested inside that we need a
margin bottom of 0.22
rem finally let's have track information
and paragraph tag we'll have the font
size
of
0.83 rem and a font weight of 300 and a
color as well that we'll add so let's
add up a color here rgba 2 6 256
256
256 and 0.8 okay so that's uh that's in
terms of the css
and let's move to the track and we'll
move into the javascript file so let's
move into so let me take what we added
in the search bar i'll go to the
track.js
this will change to track dot css
okay the constructor this will change to
add track so add track change this to
add track this is
remove track change this to remove track
get rid of this
and that's going to be
the add track function and here we're
going to say uh this dot props
so we'll modify this this dot
props
dot on add this dot props dot track and
then we have
the remove track so that's going to be
the remove track function this function
is not required so this dot prop start
on
remove
and this is the track that we would want
to go and remove we'll add up another
function called
render action so this is going to be a
function uh that we are defining called
render action and in this we'll just
check if this dot props dot is
remove if this dot props dot is
removal so in that case
we would want to return so this is a
view action method that we are adding
which is going to go and add this button
with a class called as track action that
we've already written the css for and
this button will actually get added
via this render action function and this
dot
remove track is what it's going to map
to let's close this
this is going to point to this specific
function so that's uh the closing button
tag okay so the closing button tag is
what
we've added there and the binding is
what we have done to this dot
remove track and
we will terminate this here so now the
render action uh let's also have the
return here and we just add up the
button and this is going to add track so
you can look at how the component is
completely dynamic uh in nature so we
have two buttons that are going to be
added this button with the hyphen is
going to remove the track this button uh
with the plus sign is going to add the
track and you can actually see how
simply it was done in a render action
function so the render action function
actually helped
with
checking that if
on the value of the props
and if the user
depending on
the action performed you will actually
be able to remove a track or add a track
from the existing playlist okay and then
the class name here is now going to be
track the class name for
uh the enclosing div inside it so let me
get rid of this the class name for the
enclosing div here
is going to be track dash
information within it we'll add h3 we'll
bind to this dot props dot track dot
name so the name of the track is going
to get bound here then in the paragraph
we will bind to this dot props
dot track dot artist
and
with some gap this dot props dot track
dot argo so that's what
we've data bound to
and then let me add an iframe an iframe
allows us to uh very easily inject some
content into the page within a small
embedded window the source parameter
of the frame is going to be https
open dot so here i'm connecting to the
spotify stream
spotify.com slash embed slash track and
close this so that's the spotify stream
that we're going to connect to and this
dot props dot track dot id so that's the
track id the width is going to be 300
the height parameter this the height
parameter is going to be 80 of the
iframe and
the frame border is going to be zero
and the allow
transparency so that's the opacity we'll
say true let's add allow
encrypted media so if spotify has
encrypted media that also would be
embedded here and we can also have the
title set to preview so that's uh with
the iframe okay at the bottom is where
we would want to so this could be an
empty element and we can close it
right around here so we wouldn't need
this part and then here i am just going
to say this dot
render action so we call the render
action method uh which will actually
give us plus minus button to add and
remove uh
new element okay and that's uh what we
can actually go and add up there so
let's check now whether uh all that
we've done is good to go fine so
everything looks good
in terms of the track component now and
we have all of the functions in place
it's now time to jump into the
next component that we would require
after the track component and
that's going to be the track list so
this is going to be a list component
that will comprise of a list of tracks
inside it so we'll create a new folder
call this track list and that's going to
have
track list css
and it's going to have track list dot js
so that's the track list
component now which
we're going to go ahead and use
and the css we don't need much so let's
just say track list
and we just provide a width of 100
okay that's all we need uh in the css so
let me add this in the css file save
this
and come to the js file now which is
going to have
the track list code that we will need to
add up so here again i'm going to say
import react
from react we'd also want to import
track list dot css
and
we
also want to go and get track because
this component is going to be made up of
a collection of tracks
individual tracks so we want to get this
from track slash track and we'll define
class track list which is going to go
and extend
react dot
component
we just need the render method here
because this just needs to go it does
not really have any state of itself it
simply goes and returns a list of
individual tracks
so this class name is going to be
track list
and we'll bind to this dot props dot
tracks dot map create a temporary
variable
and this will go and return
the track component
which is going to bind to individual
track data the key is going to be track
dot id so the key is going to be track
dot id
and on add on adding a new track we want
to bind to this dot properties dot and
we already have on add defined so that's
what we connect to add up my
base bracket here okay and
then we would also need
is
removal
equal to
this dot props dot is
removal and the on remove will do this
dot drop start on remove so that's for
the track removal
so we've got our track list
uh oh yes we'll have to go and
also close the tip tag correctly and
also we need to go and export
so we'll have to go and export
the track
list
so we've got one more component done
which is track list and let's move on to
the next component now so we've got app
which is root we've got the search bar
that takes care of entering the search
criteria we've got individual tracks
that are searched and returned and we've
got a track list that manages a set of
track records so the track is more
relevant to the playlist and then we've
got the search results also to manage
once we search for some
set of tracks so we'll add a new folder
which manages search results
and this is going to have
search results dot css
and it's going to have
search results dot js
okay so we need a search results dot css
and js and here in the css file we'll
keep it simple for the search results so
we say search results we'll set up the
width of 50 percent we
set up the height of 950
pixels
we'll say
overflow y is
scroll we'll say padding is 0.88
rem background color will be rgba
95 23 23 0.7
and we will use the box model so we'll
provide a shadow dropping shadow of zero
four pixels to pixels to pixels
ash
and then
let's add
a scroll bar so
webkit
and mozart are the constants specific to
mozilla and
chrome browsers
so they target certain animated features
etc or properties
that are specific to those individual
browsers that's the reason we use those
constants
and then we'll also add a media query
that if it goes with a max
with one zero two zero pixels
in that case dot search
results
with is 90 percent
with a margin bottom of 2 rdm okay so
we're going to add hyphen so it's hyphen
webkit scroll bar zero pixel width
and we've set
transparent background so that's that's
about it with
the css i need to get to the uh js file
now let's move to the search results
js file and that's where we will now
have to go and add up
the component code for search results
and let me take
pick this up from track list add it up
here this would be
search results and
we need the results will return to us a
list of tracks so we'll have to get uh
track list this would be track list
and
i'm just going to return class name will
also be
search results so that's the component
and this is going to export out search
results so it's accessible across
other components then we've got h2 with
results
let's go and create
track list with a set of tracks and we
will find it to this dot props dot
search results and on the on add we are
going to bind to this dot props dot on
add so we already have that so that
basically completes
search results and
that leaves us with the last component
which is going to manage the playlist
for us so we'll add up a new books we'll
add up a new folder in components
and that's going to be playlist
and within that we will have a playlist
dot css
and
a playlist dot js
so that's our
playlist component now that
we're going to work with and the
playlist component
is
uh we'll first set up
the css that we will need
to add up to the playlist and i'm just
going to
pick that up from my code snippet so
that's my playlist and let me get all of
that css here so that's uh just a css
for the playlist nothing to do with
react again pure css
let me get
into the js file and that's where we
will need to go and add all of our
component code so again let me go to the
track.js
the track list rather let me get this
and add it out here we'll make some
small changes this is going to be
playlist
i need to import the track list
because the playlist is going to contain
a list of tracks this is going to be
playlist and
let me
here this will be playlist and we'll
leave this
for later okay let me also get
the constructor in so we'll add up the
constructor here and just one function
that we will need here which is handle
name change you know if i need to change
the name of the playlist so handle name
change and that's exactly the function
that we will need to write code for so
that's the event
and this dot props
dot on name change that's when we'll say
event dot
target dot value so we get the updated
playlist name coming to the render we
now need the input
input
is going to be on change equal to this
dot
handle name change
the default
value we have already provided with a
hard coded value which is new playlist
so that's the default value if
not provided then we'll just pick up the
default value then we've got uh track
list so track list is what i will add
the tracks i'm going to bind to this dot
props dot playlist
tracks
so we're going to bind this to playlist
tracks
and here we will say
is
removal equal to
true and on remove
equal to we'll find that to this dot
props
dot on remove
finally we'll need a button we will use
class name equal to playlist
dash
save that's what we've added in the css
click equal to this dot props
dot on save and here we're going to say
save to
spotify so that's with the
playlist and yes we need to go and
export playlist and not track list
now we'll need to uh do a quick look up
in spotify so let's go to this website
called developer.spotify.com
and once once we sign in
and create an id it takes us to our
dashboard
that's where we can create a sample
application the name of the application
will be
musical file okay and uh we'll say that
we are building uh
some kind of desktop app for example for
which we want to uh connect this to and
we'll also need to provide uh so we'll
say next
refresh the dashboard so it's uh
asking me for a login so let me login
once more so moment i login that's going
to be description and i'll say maybe
this is why i need it i'll say no not
commercial integration agree with the
terms and conditions and we will say
submit
and that's the application that has got
created and now i can say edit settings
and
the redirect url here is what is
important
so it should accept connections from
http localhost 3000 that's the port on
which we will host our application okay
and we'll say save okay so that's uh
now there's a client id that is
generated here for my app which is
unique so i'll just copy that up let me
come up to my application under the
source folder i'm going to add a new
folder called util and under that a new
file called spotify.js
so we will start with
adding our code to the spotify.js file
that we've just created as a new file
within the newly created util folder the
first line of code is going to define a
client id variable that equates to the
client id that we will generate on
spotify so this is going to be the
spotify generated client id which is a
unique id associated for the developer
to connect to the spotify api and we
will look at uh the source of that as we
go through the demo the next variable
that we'll create is the redirect url or
let's call it redirect uri and that will
equate to localhost colon 3000 which is
the port and we'll create another
variable called the access token let's
also create another constant variable
called spotify and this will work like a
function expression so we'll equate it
to a function called get access token
and we will say if access token is true
then return the access token now let's
declare a constant variable called
access token match
which will be equal to window dot
location dot href dot match
and we will say this is equal to access
token which will be equal to and we will
give a reject expression to do a pattern
match ampersand so that we can actually
get into the url and extract
the token information from that and
hence uh the pattern match is crucial
here another constant
variable called
expires in match
equal to window dot location dot href
dot match here we will read the expiry
information using another hx expression
from the url ampersand asterisk so
that's the second constant variable
we've created now we will say if access
token match and
expires in match in that case
the access token should be equal to
access token match of 1. then we create
a variable called
expires in equal to we'll do a typecast
to number and we will take the first
parameter from the expires in match
that's done then we will say window dot
set timeout and we are going to say
access token equal to comma
expires in multiplied by thousand then
we will say window dot history dot push
state and we will say access token will
pass the second parameter as null the
last parameter as slash and close this
and we will return access token else
we will say const access
url equal to https
accounts.spotify.com
slash
authorize
client underscore id equal to dollar
client id ampersand response type equal
to token ampersand scope equal to
playlist dash
modify so we are actually building the
url that will now get generated so we'll
say modify dash public and redirect
url equal to dollar redirect uri so we
have constructed the url now that will
go out and get generated in the browser
and here we are going to say window dot
location equal to access url then we'll
add the search criteria function which
accepts a term as a parameter to search
on here we will say constant access
token equal to spotify dot get access
token so we get a reference to the same
access token return we call the fetch
function and we're going to pass
https
api dot
spotify.com slash
v1 slash
search question mark that's the query
string that we will add type equal to
track and ampersand g equal to dollar
and we will pass term comma as the
header information we will need to pass
the authorization where we will say that
the error is dollar access token dot
then response
return response dot json dot then so the
return of this function once it
completes we will then call the next
function so json response and then we
will say
return response dot json after that
another 10 block so we'll now say json
response
and if
not
json response
dot tracks
in that case we will return
an empty array else
we will return json response dot tracks
dot items dot and we will pass
we'll create track as
a variable with a lambda expression and
we'll create a temporary json object
with id and that's where we want to
associate track dot id that was returned
as the search result the name is going
to be associated with track dot name the
artist is going to be associated with
track dot artists of zero dot name the
album is going to be track dot album dot
name and the uri we will equate track
dot url so that completes uh this block
will open the next
and we this will be the save playlist
which will take the name and the track
uris and here we will check if not
name or
not track uris dot len in that case we
simply return out of the code and then
we declare a constant variable called
access token which will be equal to
spotify dot get access token so we get a
reference to the access token we then
declare headers authorization bearer is
going to be dollar access token and we
create a user id and now we will return
the fetch result where we will pass
https
api dot spotify dot com slash v1 slash
me so that's the url comma headers
will be the header information then we
call the then function declare response
as a variable use the lambda expression
and access response dot json we use the
then block to declare json response
here we say user id equal to
jsonresponse.id
and then we return fetch
https
api.spotify.com
slash v1
slash users slash taller of user id
slash
playlist so this is how we've
constructed the urls manually here we
will say assign headers to the headers
variable we'll assign method as post so
the data is sent as part of the body and
not as part of the url and as the body
we will say json.stringify
to convert this parameter name and then
we will generate a response variable to
response.json
and then we'll create json response with
the lambda operation we'll create a
constant playlist id which is equal to
json response dot id we will return
fetch
https
api.spotify.com
v1 users
dollar user id slash playlist slash
dollar again we are constructing the url
so playlist id will be replaced here
then we will say tracks
and close this comma and here again we
will say headers would equate to the
headers variable we constant headers and
this
close here okay everything fixed now so
here we're going to say headers should
equate to headers and
the method is going to be post and
the body is going to be json dot
stringify uris
track uris and we close this we close
this block we close this block and we
close this block so that completes our
code of course one more thing we have to
do which is export this class out so
export default spotify and that
completes the code for
the
spotify.js which is part of our utils
class so let's move on now to the next
step so
uh here is
the client id that we'll have to exactly
match so i'll copy this client id and
provide it here so that's the client id
that we actually need and we could also
store it
out here
so that's the
client id and that's the redirect url
that we've also defined there and we
just create an access token if your
access token is true we return access
token so the access token is something
that we are going to do a match from uh
the moment we try and connect with this
particular url and you can look here
that this is the access url that we are
trying to connect with okay with the
client id and post fixed with the
redirect url right and then i've got a
simple search function which returns an
observable so we try to fetch data using
the search term that we provided okay we
try to fetch data using the search term
provided if we are successful we get a
response of the data and accordingly
we'll iterate over the json response and
get a list of tracks out of it and do a
mapping of this json object to the track
id name artist information album name
etc and here just like a data access
layer very similar to a data access
layer we've got a save function which
will save this data to spotify as well
so i've got a save playlist and i've got
search so these are the two functions
which will go and connect to the spotify
service
by using this client id
and it will allow me to
access that information in terms of
returning a stream of json data and will
then allow me to
go ahead and push that json data into
our application so now we
actually need to start up the
application so i'll go to the terminal
and rather let me go to view and
bring out the terminal so this is the
integrated terminal that's there in the
tool and it just opens powershell from
which you can actually fire your
commands so i'm going to say node
package manager npm start to actually
start up this application so that's
going to do a full compile and
so we will fire this up give access so i
need to grant access
to that port 3000
let's give it time to run and that's the
app now that
you can actually see here so this is uh
the search bar that we actually had okay
then we had the results we had the
playlist now the results is going to
consist of
a set of tracks which are maintained by
the track list and then you can take
individual tracks with the plus and
minus button and add them into the
playlist okay so that's how
it's typically going to work okay so as
you can view here i am just going to
search for an artist
and we click on the search button it
goes to spotify tries to connect there
and says
that i need to agree to the terms and
conditions and i've just agreed to that
so the very fact that it actually uh
gave us uh a confirmation link the
moment we tried to connect and execute
our application uh that's proof enough
that it actually went and connected to
the
service there and try to return a value
to us so this is what we did we just
added an artist we said search
and you can see now it's successfully
connected i've got a list of tracks
available from this artist and you can
see the plus buttons getting added on
the fly so that was the render action
these are
buttons that got added onto this list of
tracks dynamically the moment the search
results returned a value
so i can click on this plus sign and you
can see that the track gets added to the
playlist okay as in when i click here so
i've added a couple of tracks
uh if i go back to my dashboard of my
music file application and that i've
created here in the developers portal of
spotify on
developers.spotify.com it's blank so now
i'm going to click on save to spotify
okay and that clears the playlist
so let me come here
and
now when i come out here we saw that it
actually got
successfully connected out here now i'll
have to log in to so this was the
development app that we actually created
on the developers portal of spotify now
we will go to spotify.com
so i'll just go to the spotify website
and it says do you want to launch the
web player and all that so let me click
on that so it just launches
and can you see here this is the new
playlist
that just got added right and there were
four songs that i'd actually added to
the playlist and you can see here those
four songs have got added out here okay
so i can go here and
i can delete this playlist and say i
want to delete it okay so there's no
playlist now i'll go back here
i'll add two tracks and i'll say save to
spotify so that's how you actually saw
that the new playlist you can see the
new playlist has come back here okay and
that's the playlist the playlist has got
generated again and that's the new
playlist that
got created and we deleted it but it
still got created again and that
indicates the connectivity
that we successfully created with this
react app and the core concept of the
react app was breaking it down into
components which is the search component
then we created the track component we
created the track list to maintain a
list of tracks
then we created the search results which
will generate a list of results which
further contains a track list and this
is the embedded iframe which gave us the
response which is scrollable here and
you can see that the iframes we created
allowed us to scroll this with this
embedded web page inside the iframe
container so with that uh i hope we've
been successful with explaining the
concept of component based design and
architecture with react and how
important it is to create individual
components and the benefit of that being
that you can isolate change requests to
a certain component you can promote
reusability wherever you want the same
feature to be implemented on the page
you can just inject that same component
and the same implementation and the same
features can be reused so it promotes
reusability it promotes flexibility to
change it isolates your change request
to single components preventing the
massive effort of recompiling and
retesting the entire application as a
whole
in this session we'll be comparing the
three cutting edge ui development
technologies that is react.js angular
and vue we learn about the key
differences that make them so distinct
all of these technology stacks have been
replacing pure server-side technologies
and we've slowly progressed from
server-side applications to more
distributed applications where a part of
the job is done on the client side and
apart on the server side and now we've
transitioned to something known as
single page applications or sba and all
of these technologies that you see on
your screen right now are based purely
on javascript as a result they're
lightweight and aren't dependent on any
third-party runtime tools so let's
compare the three technologies and learn
about the factors that make them stand
out first we'll look into the salient
features now react is the front-end
javascript library while angular and vue
are javascript frameworks now although
the terms library and frameworks are
used interchangeably they're
significantly different now library is a
set of classes or functions and the user
is in complete control to call them
frameworks on the other hand are like
models they have limited choices and
come with a blueprint of their own and
as a result the user doesn't have much
control so javascript being an
interpreted language where code is
executed line by line makes all these
tools very efficient mainly because
converting the code into an intermediate
code would require a runtime environment
and would definitely encounter a delay
now these are avoided and as a result
these tools are fast moving on react is
used to develop mobile and web
applications and angular is used for
single page applications and you can
also develop hybrid applications using
the stack mainly because it's purely
based on css html javascript and jquery
single page applications as the name
suggests are built using single page now
the entire page is broken down into
several components wherein each
component performs a specific task say
for example one component handles the
login the other one would display icons
and images and so on all these bits or
components are then put together to form
a single page application and moving on
react was developed and maintained by
facebook while angular was built by
google and view was developed by evan
unx google employee now react represents
the view part of the mvc framework and
angular is a full-fledged mvc framework
in itself and view on the other hand is
focused on view and the model layer of
the mvc framework now what exactly is
the mvc framework now mvc framework is
an object-oriented design principle that
mandates the separation of control
meaning one thing can only do one thing
so the model deals with the entity
classes the data and the business logic
while vue deals with the representation
and the ui logic of the application and
the controller drives the functionality
of the two any changes can be easily
factored and isolated and as a result
testing becomes a whole lot easier
moving on now let's look at the use
cases from the business perspective in
terms of react we have top websites like
facebook instagram netflix that use
react on the other hand we have angular
that is used by nike hbo forbes sony and
vue is commonly used by alibaba.com
grammarly 9gag and adobe moving on we
have performance now performance is a
very crucial feature now the moment you
build an html view and render it into
the browser this view to the user is
basically just html tags however if you
look at the internal working the code is
actually converted into a balanced tree
structure this b3 algorithm is extremely
fast so when the user makes any changes
to the ui the changes are reflected
immediately this is facilitated by the
b3 algorithm so as a result the
performance is improved so how does
react make use of this tool it uses a
virtual dom dom is an api developed by
w3c it stands for document object model
and defines how the document is accessed
and manipulated this dom parser converts
the html code into an inverse balance
tree structure so react uses the virtual
dom while angular uses the real dom and
vue uses the virtual dom again now the
virtual dom looks at the differences
between the current and the previous
html pages and only changes the parts
that need to be updated angular on the
other hand updates the entire tree
structure regardless of any changes made
or not and view again only updates the
ones that have changed since there is no
time spent on making unnecessary changes
to the entire tree react is extremely
fast on the other hand real dorm
updation is time-consuming risky and
error-prone vue also ensures faster and
bug-free performance now let's talk
about data binding the core reason why
we would use single page applications
now consider a scenario where you log
into an e-commerce website as the user
one then you should be able to see the
items in your shopping cart while user
two would be seeing different items in
their shopping carts and so on so
identifying the user and retrieving data
corresponding to that specific user is
facilitated using the help of data
binding data binding is a process that
allows an internet user to manipulate
web page elements using a web browser
now it is used in interactive components
such as calculators tutorials games etc
now react supports one-way data binding
meaning you can take the data from the
view and push it to the model or vice
versa angular on the other hand uses a
two-way data binding while vue also uses
a similar two-way data binding in react
every time the model state updates the
view changes accordingly however the
reverse is not true in case of angular
any changes made to the view are
immediately reflected in the model part
of the architecture view follows the
same principle now this hugely
influences the performance due to
one-way data binding react is modular
and fast improving the performance
angular's two-way data binding adversely
affects the performance and view on the
other hand performs according to the
input type moving on to scripting
languages react combines ui templates
and javascript logic resulting in a new
language called jsx so react only
requires the knowledge of javascript
angular uses templates again in html you
can also inject javascript code into
html using a clever implementation in
angular called directives so you can
create a class and then inject it into
html angular also does something better
you can also write code for an angular
application using a newer language
developed by microsoft called typescript
it is a compiled language and is very
similar to java and c-sharp in terms of
syntax now vue again uses html based
template it uses html5 throughout for
the ui and the combination of javascript
for business logic all view templates
are valid html and can be passed by html
parsers let's move on to testing now
just is a framework or an api that is
developed by facebook and is used to run
tests on react applications to ensure
that they are bug free now it is
embedded typically in every react
library and requires zero configuration
now angular on the other hand uses the
jasmine framework now this framework
allows various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases this also
ensures that the application is error
free the view cli or the command line
interpreter has built-in options for
unit testing with the help of jest or
mocha now view typically has single file
components and hence these components
can be tested in isolation this makes it
modular and extremely fast now let's
talk about community support since all
these tools are open source they have a
large developer community there are a
few popular github repositories for
react such as react.js 101 react.js.org
and so on you can raise queries solve a
few and connect with the larger
community that's working on react here
are a few repositories for angular view
also has a few popular repositories you
can commit download third party plugins
and also explore these stacks even
deeper all of them surely have a very
happening community at the time of
writing there were about 1 million
repositories 5 million comments and 1
million issues with respect to react
here are the figures for angular and
here are the figures for view according
to npm stat over the past two years
there have been approximately 360
million react js downloads there have
been around 38 million downloads for
angular and around 63 million downloads
for vue now let's look at the future
scope learning a new technology always
comes with questions like what's in it
for me what's its growth potential how
far will it take me in my career and so
on so let's go ahead and see the growth
rate of react angular and vue according
to google trends over the past 12 months
react has been on a way faster upward
trajectory than angular and vue which
have considerably lost their momentum
now this indicates that react is growing
faster than the other two with respect
to popularity industry adoption and
community support in this session
we are actually going to look at
how do we connect react.js with node.js
so a very warm welcome to this session
on react.js connectivity with node.js
and in this session we are going to
focus on how do we connect our react.js
application with the node.js platform so
we are going to dive into creating a
hands-on demo which will have two parts
to it we would have the client
application that we will first create as
a react application we will then create
an express.js application with node.js
and we will then try to connect both of
those applications together so
express.js is a rapid application
development framework that allows us to
create a web application very quickly on
the node.js platform and we'll use it to
create a custom api and then connect
that endpoint to the react.js client
application so let's dive into our demo
and
let's start with creating our client and
node express applications and see how to
set them up and then get them connected
to each other let's start with our
hands-on demo and we will first go to
the node.js website nodejs.org we can
download the lts version which is a
stable version of node.js moment i click
on this it will prompt me for a download
it will download tmsi file and then all
i need to do is double click on it keep
clicking on the next button and install
that would install node.js for us next
we'll open our editor you can use any
editor of your choice so i'm going to
use
an editor called
visual studio code and let's open up the
terminal here and i also have the
command prompt open where i've navigated
to a folder that i've created called
react.js demos now we'll invoke the npm
package manager which is invoked by the
command npx so npx will not only install
packages but also execute them once they
are installed so once they are
downloaded it will execute the package
and
we will use npx to go and create a react
application called client so while we
give it time for the installation to
complete we can then open it
within our editor so we'll give it time
so that the installation completes
so the installation is completed and so
we've seen here that the installation is
now completed and let's uh go and open
up this project so i will say file and
open folder and
let me pick up that folder and we will
open this application called client so
that's my client app let's fire up
the terminal so
okay so that has launched the terminal
for us
and here
all we need to do to fire up this
application and get it running is npm
start which will compile and start up
this application that is created let's
close this we'll go to the browser and
now let's say localhost 3000 so that
gives us a startup page the sample uh
default startup page for the first
client application uh and this is going
to work as our client will now go and
try to create uh the backend uh
application which is going to be another
application that we will set up and to
create that
let's say npx express
generator api okay so this will create
an express application on node.js called
api and let's give it some time for
installation okay so that's done clear
this screen we'll come out here we'll
open another instance of the editor
we'll say open folder and that's the api
application we'll say select folder and
the api application is opened let's go
to the terminal now in the terminal we
will attempt to install all of the
packages that are required that would be
logged in the package.json file so the
package.json file here would be listed
so you can see we have a list of
packages that it uses and npm install
will go and install all of these
packages that were pre-listed here so
let me ensure it's executed correctly
and we'll fire that once more that's
done so npm install has installed all of
the packages required and let me
terminate this run by pressing a control
c so this terminates
the client application that was
executing and now we will say npm start
so that this application executes and
let's refresh
so that's the standard express
application now that has got installed
now let's go to the api application
we'll go into the bin folder and here
we'll have a file called www we will
change the default port number from 3000
to 9000 let me stop this application
from executing we've just updated the
port number now let's go to the routes
and we'll create a new file in the
routes folder called test api dot js
here we will say variable express
equal to require
express and here we'll say variable
router equal to express dot
router and here we will say
router dot get will open this
so that's the default route route route
is going to be slash for which we'll add
a callback function which will take the
request and the response parameter and
next pointer in case there is another
function to call post that and here we
will just send a simple message saying
api is working okay a simple message
sent out for the root default route and
we'll have to export this so we'll say
module dot exports equal to router all
right so that's uh done let's go to the
app.js file and here let us import that
so here is where we will import this
by saying app.use we want to use the
test api file and that is
test api router and this is exactly the
same variable name that we will declare
here which will be equal to require and
we are going to say routes
test api all right so let's try
launching this now we would say npm
start after adding this code let's go
out here and 3000 test api is going to
be the url to hit it's not 3000 but 9000
now because we just updated the port so
9000 test api and there we have a
message which says that the api is
working properly so this is tested now
let's go to the client application in
the client application let's go to the
app.js file okay this is the file that
we would have to revamp a bit so let's
uh revamp this here we will declare a
class app which extends so that creates
a new module so it extends
react.component
and here we have constructor we will
accept the props
here i would pass props to the super
class constructor and
set the state to api response
currently it just has an empty value
next we'll add up a new function called
call api which will generate a call to
that
api url which was http localhost 9000
was the port and test api was the url
once this is called we will then call
the then function declare response
generate a call to response.txt and then
we will again say this dot set state api
response
is going to be equal to the response
that comes in from that url which is
nothing but a string which says api is
working another function called
component will mount so the moment the
component is initialized on the screen
and loaded we will generate a call to
this function we created called call api
then comes
the render function in the render
function we would go and return a div
class name is app this would be app
header the standard logo after which
in the paragraph we wouldn't need the
link here right after the header we'll
add a paragraph where we will print this
dot state and the variable we created
called api response and we will data
bind to that so that largely completes
uh the return so we simply create this
application uh that's the react
application that will talk to this api
that is and this
url that is hosted on node communicate
with it get a simple string as a
response print that string inside this
react application so once that's done
we have the component wheel mount which
is a life cycle method here it's a
lifecycle event that gets triggered the
moment the component loads and that's
when we have actually gone and executed
the call api custom function let's go to
the api application we'll terminate the
execution here there's one more step
that we'll have to perform which is
cross origin
resource sharing which means that to
allow the react application to
communicate from another hosted domain
to this particular domain server we will
actually have to enable cross origin
scripting and sharing otherwise it will
block the request coming from another
application so for that we'll have to
install globally cross origin module and
dash dash save indicates that it's going
to do a global install for all
applications
that are on this particular system so
we've installed this
and we'll clear the screen let's go to
the app.js
and right here is where we would want it
to go and use cards so we will say
app.use course so that it uses this
particular api and here is where we will
declare the course variable and go and
import the new library package that we
just installed which is quartz so looks
good and now let's
fire up this application with an npm
start let's also fire up client with an
npm start and now when i go and
try looking for localhost 3000 which is
the react application the react
application should go and talk to the
api that is hosted on node.js which
returns to me that string message so if
i go and ping that api separately which
is localhost
9000 test api you can see this is a
standard message so here i've directly
ping the api that's hosted in node.js
now we are consuming it through the
react.js application and if you scroll
down you can see the message returned
from node.js into react saying the api
is working properly so the practical
impact of this is to actually host
restful services etc on node as a server
and you can go and consume the data that
is written there could be in string text
or json format directly into the
react.js acting as a client application
hello this is matthew with simply learn
and today we're going to cover react
with redux
so why would you use redux well the
reason why you want to use redux is that
redux actually understands and helps
manage the state of an object
and redux was introduced to help address
some problems that you're having with
react so the state for an object stores
values and properties that belong to
components that could potentially change
over time so
the state could be modified by actions
in your network uh they could be
changes to the re-render of the
component in the browser
the object could also then potentially
store multiple properties
and then with redux it actually takes in
and actually will create a uh you know
take a a large application that you
could create with app with a react and
breaks it down to several components
instead of having this massive number of
states you have to manage and so every
time that you you know an application
will then switch from a current with a
react you'd actually be then changing
the states and this is a really big
problem because when you're like doing
that switching back and forth there is
the potential for applications to be
re-rendered which reduces the efficiency
of your application and so this is why
redux was introduced
so you know what is redux so redux is a
way to be able to have a predictable
state container for your javascript
applications and allow you to run your
applications in multiple different
environments so whether it's a client
solution a service solution or a native
app solution and then more importantly
um or one of the key
elements that i like about redux is that
it's really easy to test and so with
redux you're able to manage the state of
your tool
you can actually use it to work with any
javascript framework or library
and you can actually then store the um
the application and the components in a
state store which makes it easy to be
able to manage the state of your
application so in simple words redux
stores all the state objects in a single
store and organizes it it provides
information about the current state of
the application any changes in the state
the application can be described to the
store by the user and then it notifies
any modifications made to the state of
that application so let's jump into the
key principles of redux and there's
three key areas i want to focus in so
the first one is that redux provides a
single source of truth
um and that source of truth is uh being
able to store the state of your whole
application in an object tree in a
single store and this makes it easier
for you to debug and inspect uh
components of your application uh also
enables you to be able to persist your
app stage for development and improve
faster development cycles the second
principle is that state is read only and
that's why you're able to
describe more effectively what's
happening because it is read only and
this ensures that no events like network
callbacks uh would uh
create and any issues with the code and
the re-rendering of your application
and that object actions are become then
just plain objects and then finally
changes are made with pure functions and
so what do we mean by this
so we can actually
take actions and transform the state
tree with pure reducers and we'll go
into a demo later on to show you this
but a reducer is essentially a function
that accepts an accumulation value and
then it takes back and returns that as a
new accumulation and this allows you to
have a single source of truth value the
user can return the new state objects
instead of mutating to previous state
the user can
start with a single reducing as the app
grows it can then split off into a
smaller reducers
and then finally the reducers just
become functions so let's talk about the
pillars of redux
and so there are three key areas we have
the store the actions and then reducers
and then the store itself is the actual
main object that holds the application
tree state
and there are four key
states there's get state which returns
the current c to the store and when we
actually run the demo later on you'll be
able to see that we'll be able to open
up our terminal window and be able to
get the state store from from our
terminal window
the second state is dispatch and this is
a an action it's the only way to update
the application state and here we have a
action on a button change to actually
change the state of the application and
then the final two are subscribe
unsubscribe
and these are our ways in which you can
actually change the listener to the
state so an action is a plain object
that represents an intention to change
the state so with actions you have
payloads of information that send data
back and forth to your application store
so you can send any kind of data and
they can go back and forth and that
actions must also have been a tight
field that indicates the type of action
that has been performed and finally with
reducers reducers are
specified how the application state
changes in response to actions sent to
the store and so actions only describe
what's happened but don't describe the
application state change
they are reducer is a function that
accepts the current state and an action
and then returns a new state with the
action performed and then finally you
can use combined reducers utility which
can then combine reduces in an app into
a single a index
so let's look at the pros and cons of
using redux because nothing is perfect
so a pro for working with redux is that
redux provides a single source of truth
which is the store so there's no
confusion over where you're getting your
values
this then leads to having a predictable
and strict outcome redux is more
stringent about how the code is
organized this makes it easier to
onboard developers because there is a
very structured way of writing redux
code this makes it also then
easier for the initial render which
allows you to make your solution really
optimized as an experience and then
finally developers can track everything
that's going on inside the app in real
time the cons
so
one of the plate codes so this kind of
takes us back to the structured code
format it is um strict in its um setup
and it is memory intensive so with that
let's go in and look at a demo of using
redux to
reformat a react application
so in this demo we're going to use react
to show how redux can work first thing
we want to do is go ahead and download
node.js we're going to go to nodejs.org
to get the latest download the downloads
are available in windows mac os and
linux you can also download and
recompile the source code if you want
i encourage you to go with the latest
lts version it's the latest stable
version now there are other versions you
can use but that's the one you would
want to use i already have it installed
so i just want to show you how that
looks so i'm just going to go in and put
node dash dash version it's going to
give me the version number so that shows
that it's installed i'm going to also
use npm which is node package manager
because we'll be using that validate
that it's installed by doing node mpm
version so okay so looking good and
we're gonna go ahead and create a folder
um on our desktop um normally you
wouldn't put
a project folder on your desktop but you
know this is just for an experiment so
we're gonna call this one
redux react is going to be taking a
react project and we're going to show
what it looks like as a standard project
and then what it will look like
as a project that's being
taken through redux
so let's just move our cursor to the
correct folder
and so we're going to go to cd redux
react
and there we are we're in at the correct
folder using our command prompt
you use terminal on mac os
so let's just type in mpx and that's for
our redax and we're going to do create
dash react dash app so we're going to
create a default react app and then
we're going to also install redux dash
app
and these are the two
components that we need to be able to uh
build out our solution one is react and
it's react.js
and the second is redux and we hit
return
and this is going to go ahead and
download the latest versions of both of
these applications and install them into
the folder that we just created on our
desktop
just give that a moment
and so it's installing the different
packages react react dom
react scripts
and there we are have everything
installed great
and these are just different commands
you can use and it's recommending that
we select npm start
to get everything up and running so we
use visual studio code to do most of our
work here vs code
is open source solution for scripting
and it's available on all leading
platforms uh it is from microsoft but it
is open source and uh there's just a ton
of stuff here but we're gonna go ahead
and we're gonna open up the folder we
just created on our desktop
and so here is redux react app
and we're going to select that folder
and on the left hand side you'll see all
the files from that folder which is
getting rid of the welcome screen we
don't need that anymore uh you'll see
there's some commands we can use we do
control plus
uh i'm not sure what that's called again
anyway it gets us to the terminal window
um
not an exclamation point
so you'll see that in our project folder
we have all of the files we need for our
solution we have both the node modules
and then the public files the product
files is just the application itself so
over here on the index.html you see the
index file there and we're going to
actually show what this looks like
inside
as it's broadcast from a web browser in
a moment now uh we're going to create a
very simple application here
and the application is going to look
exactly the same in both um
just standard react and uh redux react
it's the optimization that's gonna be
improved so we just did mpm dash and
start it's gonna take us to localhost
called on 3000 give it a moment and then
we should get our
floating
logo showing that the application's up
and running up there we are
we can go ahead and head and edit app.js
to
create our application
okay so let's go in and we're gonna go
into app.js
and we are gonna create an application
called
newcomp.js
and we actually have some code that
we've already created that you can
download as part of this application
so but we're just going to type in here
import react
and then component
from
[Music]
react
so i'm going to pull in our react
library
and we also import
connect
from
react
redux
and that's the
package that we're working in
let's
terminate the batch job yes
and then rerun
npm
install
save
react
dash redux
and there we go takes a moment just to
install that
so our goal here is to show
how you can optimize your solution with
redux
for the
using the store and reduces in redux
again
the solution is going to look exactly
the same what's going to change is the
performance of the solution
and this is what redux gives you all
right so we're going to go ahead and
we're going to go in and type in class
new comp
extends
component
and then we're just going to select our
constructor
props
and then we want to add in there
super props
and then this
state
equals
i have a message here
subscribe
to simply learn
very simple little app don't forget to
save your work as you go along
and we're just going to apply some
styles
let's just make the
apply some font style
okay italics
then we're gonna
make the color
purple
and let's have a button that we're going
to press a
button change
equals
this set state
oh sorry get state
and we'll have a message that comes up
basically saying thank you for
subscribing
there we go we have our button we'll
change the state here in a moment
and very simple
little application
and we want to rent that
on the screen
i just have some basic html for where
we're going to place everything we use a
div tag
for our app
again we're going to keep this really
simple
and we're going to call
reference this styles for
this h3 tag
so our message is going to be subscribe
to simply learn
this will be created dynamically we use
our style
i'm gonna add in a button
we have a one click
action
subscribe
and nope change too many s's
i'll save that
all right save now let's run
that script
you guys have js
and we're going to actually import that
into
our app.js script
rid of this
and then
and we'll extend
the newscorp js
component into here
apparent
font style here
and
i'm to render this correctly
and i'll pull in the text
and styles
again it's pretty simple little
application
not playing from use code
so we'll actually have
a welcome screen a welcome line and then
pulling the two lines of code
all right let's
run that
npm start
and here we go
refreshes our page
so what we've just created is a basic
standard state object
and
let's see now oh yeah this is good now
we actually can show you that we didn't
actually write all our code correctly so
let's go back and fix that
it's newport and use
newscomp.js and we have to make sure
that we
have a correct export feature here so
that the image that the
everything can be exported effectively
and import we also need to have an
export
all right let's run that again
okay should take care of our
uh problem hey there we are so welcome
and then we have the standard state
object of subscribe to simplyline hit
subscribe and we change the text to
thank you for subscribing
okay so let's kind of go in and modify
this now so it goes from being a
standard state object to one that uses
store and reduces
so we're going to go ahead and terminate
our batch job
and since you reset everything
and what we're going to do now is
install redux
this is what's going to help us
it takes a moment to install redux
all right so we have redux installed
that's good
and now we want to
start
our package
and it looks the same but now we're
going to make some changes
so let's go to
our index file
index.js
and here's our react dom
now we're going to add in
contour
so this is going to be our react this is
going to be our redux store so we're
going to create a new store
now it's going to be a reducer
and
we're going to
put in
strict mode
okay juice is not defined let's go ahead
and define that
so
we're going to come over
to our new comp js file
and what we want to do here is we're
going
to
take out the one class file that we just
created
and
i'm just gonna stripping it down here
now let's go in
and
let's map our state
to
props
equals state
and we're going to do return
message
is state dot message
and then
construct map dispatcher props
and this is going to be our dispatch
and we're going to be in
return
and we have our button
change
for dispatch
and we'll type in what the message is
now we have message change
let's turn from the button okay
so we'll pass the value over
all right
and now we actually
connect
as parabolic export and in our
connection
i'm going to do map state props
and map
dispatch props
all right now we're going to go in and
it's going to be for our new comp
now we want to switch over
we're going to just change some of our
linking variables here
so serve to button change we're going to
do props dot button change
otherwise we won't be able to find in
our code
this is some pathing
and
you go ahead and create a new folder and
this one is going to be our store
and again this is going to be our redux
store
we're going to call the store reducer.js
and
construct initial state equals
this is what the default state will be
for when the page loads which will be
subscribed to simply then
and then
the reducer
we're going to place to where the
reducer is
and con's new state
it's going to be
an if action
dot type
i'm going to change the message
there's unused comp
so that's the
action there we're gonna
pull that
so it's identical
and then new state dot message
equals
thank you for subscribing so
we have the default and now we have the
new message
again this might seem like um extra work
but actually makes your
whole application much more efficient
export default
juicer
all right so make sure we saved all our
files which we have
and
now let's go ahead
so we have let's just inspect everything
it's all looking good
all right
now terminal window we're going to do
npm start and see what happens
and our web browser should load up
oh we have an error
that's good so now we're learning stuff
so this is again this is all part of
your standard coding is just hunting
down errors in your code so let's go to
index.js
and
looks like
we're going to pull in here
so we have reduce and this should
actually be
spelled correctly there we go
okay all right everything is now
as it should be
let's go back
recompile
let's
rerun uh
file
and do we want to move our file let's
just go ahead and move the store
i'm going to update all the links to the
store
and we're going to be trying making sure
our provider
store
is referenced correctly
okay let's re-run our application
and
there we are
so let's go back through
our application is running much faster
now
we're able to manage our changes and our
elements for our applications different
objects
we're able to change the messages after
you click
and able to then create the new message
again this is a very simple application
but you can see how for more complex
solutions how this becomes useful and
you start using the different components
you create
for your whole solution
and that's our demo
if you wish to build mobile applications
and are confused as to which tool to use
then you're in the right place
this video on react native will explain
what react native is and guide you
through it
but wait before beginning if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already then
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update
so here's what you'll be learning in
this session
first we'll understand what exactly
react native is
then we look at why react native is
being so widely used off lately
moving ahead we look at the differences
between react native applications and
platform specific applications
after understanding why react native is
used we'll understand some of the
prerequisites for building applications
using react native
then we'll understand react native
fundamentals like view state props and
style
and lastly we'll end the session by
looking at some of the industry trends
of react native
so let's begin
what exactly is react native
now react native is a framework that
combines the best parts of native
development with react to build user
interfaces
these applications that are developed
using react native are downloadable on
google play store and apple store plus
because most of the code you write can
be shared between platforms react native
offers a wide collection of ui kits and
makes it easy to simultaneously develop
for both android and ios devices
but you must be wondering why is react
native used
so let's look at some of the reasons why
react native is used
first up is cross platform
cross platform means that the
applications can easily be run on
microsoft windows linux and mac os
so you can build your code base once and
then run it on any platform as opposed
to software built natively for a
specific platform next up is performance
now the react native apps are compiled
into natively written code which enables
it to not only work on both the
operating systems but also functions the
same way on both the platforms with no
lags at all
moving ahead there's quicker development
now react native offers excellent
developer experience it provides strong
developer and debugging tools with
meaningful error messages so working
with this tool becomes very easy
a large developer community now there
are several github repositories on react
native and groups on facebook
stack overflow is an excellent website
with several developers interacting
about issues on a regular basis
next up is wider audience
now since react native applications run
on both ios and android devices there's
a huge user base
and lastly react native has a great
career scope
considering the pace at which the
framework took over the market and its
simple approach to resolving development
problems the future of react native
looks more promising than ever
so these were some of the reasons why
react native is being widely adopted
so now let's go ahead and look at some
of the differences between react native
applications and platform-specific
applications
as discussed earlier react applications
work on multiple platforms while in the
case of platform-specific applications
as the name suggests these applications
are built for the specific platform only
developers have a stronger web
development background while in the case
of platform-specific apps they have a
very strong platform's language
background
in this case when you consider ios
developers have a very strong hold of
swift which is a programming language
used to develop ios applications and
talking about android developers have a
very strong hold on java
when it comes to react native it has a
faster build time and is less suitable
for complex applications
comparatively platform specific
applications have a slower build time
and are suitable for complex
applications
react native is best for small
development teams with limited resources
while in the case of platform-specific
applications it is best used by
experienced developers who have adequate
experience in building mobile apps
now that you know what exactly is the
difference between react native and
platform specific applications let's
look at some of the prerequisites for
building apps using react native
first up you should have a strong
holding programming concepts like
functions objects arrays and to lesser
extent classes
now understanding javascript and all the
javascript libraries and frameworks is
crucial
and lastly you need to be familiar with
html and css concepts so as long as you
have a strong hold of these then react
native development becomes very easy
so now that you know what react native
is you've understood why it's being used
some of the prerequisites for react
native
let's look at the basic concepts like
view state props and styling in react
native
let's begin with view
now view is the most fundamental
component of building a ui it is a
container that supports layout with
flexbox style some touch handling and
accessibility controls
now view maps directly to the native
view
equivalent on whatever platform react
native is running on so here you can see
there's a simple code snippet and the
output for it so as you can see there's
a hello world message in a render method
and the same is being rendered and the
view component here is being imported
from react native
now view as mentioned earlier acts as a
container with support for flexbox
layout and other styles
so flexbox is designed to provide a
consistent layout on different screen
sizes
moving on to state now there are two
types of data that control a component
one is props and the other one is state
now props are generally set by the
parent and are fixed throughout the
lifetime of a component
but for data that is going to change we
make use of state
so here you can see you have made use of
the this dot stay dot my state in my
render method you can also use the set
state method when you want to change it
moving on let's look at props
most components can be customized when
they are created with different
parameters these created parameters are
called props short for properties now
props are passed from one container to
another as a way of passing data between
them
so here using the name as a prop
lets us customize the message in the
component so we can reuse our component
for each of our tv shows here
so this is how we can use props in our
component
lastly talking about style react native
uses the conventional javascript
styling for components so the style
names and values are similar to how css
works
now to style we either use inline style
or style sheet
so you can see here we've provided
inline styling with a background color
a color and a font size and accordingly
the output is displayed moving ahead to
our last and final section
let's look at the industry trends today
talking about salaries the average
salary of a react native developer in
india is around 6 lakh indian rupees per
annum
and the salary of a react native
developer in the us is around 96 000 us
dollars per annum now as you can see
react native has a higher growth
trajectory compared to other frameworks
as a result is being readily deployed by
many companies
applications like facebook instagram
netflix
pinterest uber uber eats among others
are developed using react native in this
session we would look at identifying
some of the differences between the
react native and flutter frameworks
let's start with understanding the core
areas of comparison as part of this
session we will be looking at key
aspects to identify differences between
both the frameworks predominantly on the
language front the ui aspect the
performance the documentation the
popularity
the community support that is available
for both these frameworks along with the
industry trends
in terms of the industry adoption for
both these platforms the core objective
of the session would be that at the end
you should be able to decide and make an
informed decision as to which framework
is the best among those available let's
start from a language perspective
now if you look at react react is
basically completely written and built
in javascript using the react.js api on
the other hand if you look at flutter it
is basically written in a very new
language called as start and we do not
have uh too many developers that are
skilled on dart however uh every browser
and every platform being shipped with uh
an inbuilt javascript execution
environment that makes javascript
platform the language of choice
for developers so every browser today or
every browser manufacturer would have
inbuilt support for executing javascript
programs similarly most popular
platforms mobility platforms like
android and ios have default support for
executing javascript programs and that's
the reason when you compare this with
flutter flutter uses dart which is
predominantly a newer language and we
really do not have too many developers
who are skilled on this so that really
is the selling point
and the usp of react native because when
you work with react native uh you really
do not have to relearn a lot you don't
have a sharp learning curve most of the
javascript developers who are working
with means tag already works with html
css and dhtml can easily align to this
that as we have discussed
is pretty new in the industry and would
not have that much of penetration in the
developer community from a ui
perspective when you talk about react
native it's based pretty much on native
components for the android and the ios
platform and flutter on the other hand
uses a very proprietary
set of widgets and it has its own page
structure that needs to be set up so
it's a closed ecosystem as compared to
an open ecosystem in react native which
allows you to go and implement third
party widgets and ui frameworks as well
now this is really what allows you to
pick and choose with react native
because you can go and decide whether
you want to use kendo ui or a set of
terry controls or any other third party
ui framework can be implemented but for
flutter you have a pretty closed
ecosystem and that's the reason the ui
components that are available out of the
box and built into the platform are all
that you can use from a performance
perspective when you talk about react
native it basically
is built and uses javascript out of the
box and that's the reason when you want
to write any code in javascript that
connects and tries to access native
services on that specific platform it
uses a bridge to do that but when you're
using flutter on the other hand flutter
does not need any kind of bridge so
there's no concept of you write flutter
code and then it uses a bridge to go and
connect to the native set of components
to interact with and this is what really
impacts the speed and the performance
aspect of developing and executing
applications between both these
frameworks because if you look at react
the speed of development is a little bit
slower when you compare that with
flutter and that's because it has an
intermediate bridge that it has to
communicate with and every layer of
additional communication and computation
that you put in between two tiers in a
application that you built obviously
would have a performance impact from a
documentation perspective if we were to
compare flutter typically has a very
well defined documentation repository
and it allows developers to go through
it in a very simple manner so it's all
structured it's all organized unlike
what you see on react native because in
react native it actually since react
native is an open ecosystem and allows
you to implement third party widgets and
you can do a lot of configuration and
plug and play and that's the reason uh
the documentation also is not very
strong well organized and impactful and
that's the reason uh most developers
would find it a little challenging to go
through the react native documentation
when you compare that to the
documentation available in terms of
flutter popularity is always a key when
working with platforms and that should
be a crucial decision maker because when
it comes to open source technologies and
you're stuck somewhere you obviously go
to the coming to the community to go and
find out how best you can solution the
problem now flutter being relatively a
new entrant into the market it does not
have a lot of developer penetration and
that's the reason the popularity in the
community is not very strong react
native being there for a while now it's
been around for some time and that's the
reason uh it's pretty popular among
developers also since uh it uses
javascript it's a natural transition and
a progression path for those who are
working with html5 css building web
applications or have been building
hybrid mobile apps find it very easy to
migrate to this because flutter requires
you to learn a new programming language
which is start and that is one more
reason why the popularity of this is
much much better on the react native
front as compared to flutter again if
you look at google trends
you could actually look at both of the
lines here the red line indicating
flutter it started on a very positive
note and then there was a plateau and
then suddenly a spike react native has
been much more steady in terms of its
growth and ultimately if you look at it
now both of them seem to be trending at
par with each other so the community
support as we were speaking about if you
look at stack overflow which is one of
the most popular websites to go for any
kind of
developer
trends and movements and for a q a that
most developers would have you can
actually look at the number of questions
here and uh also uh react native is part
of uh github as its open source it was
released in 2015 and uh it's because of
the huge community support that it
becomes uh easier to implement this you
have a lot of confidence as a developer
when you start building on this stack
because if you're stuck somewhere you
will have a lot of help available on the
way on the other hand if you compare
that with flutter you could look at the
question count here on stack overflow
and this being a new entrant in the
market uh it has a smaller footprint on
the community aspect but of course that
keeps increasing every day again from a
react native perspective and you talk
about stability in terms of stable
releases
there again you would see that react
native does a much better job as
compared to flutter so the industry
tents are something which all of us have
to be aware of specifically if
we would need to make a decision in
terms of our careers the technology that
we are learning what is the growth
aspect what is the industry adoption and
how we could really move ahead on our
career graphs in terms of the
opportunities market the job market etc
so again getting back to stack overflow
which is the benchmark for understanding
technology trends in ide sphere and
software development if you look at a
recent survey conducted in 2019 uh 62.5
percent of developers uh seem to have
shown interest in react native as
compared to a marginal rise of 65.4
percent where flutter seems to be doing
much better and of course that could be
due to the uh time frames that uh both
these technologies uh have been around
react has been around for quite a while
and hence the job prospects are much
better a lot of organizations
implementing this clutter has been a new
entrant and hence
slightly fewer opportunities as the
penetration still needs to happen in the
opportunities job market and
from a developer skills perspective so
these are some of the big names that are
using react native in their
implementations right from facebook to
pinterest to wix skype tesla insta
bloomberg uh you can actually look at uh
the implementation across industry which
is absolutely crucial when you're
learning something new because when you
want to join a large logo obviously if
there are a lot of logos using this that
enhances the credibility of your
learning puts a justification to why you
would want to learn this technology
flutter on the other hand associated
with big names like google sonos alibaba
the largest retailer out there from a
conclusion perspective if we were to
conclude on what we've discussed from a
language perspective obviously we said
react is much more popular since it is a
natural progression for developers to
work on javascript and move to this as
compared to dart which is relatively a
new language from a ui perspective the
open source plug-and-play capability of
configuring and adopting seamlessly to
newer platforms of widgets and
third-party ui platforms are much better
as compared to flutter which is a closed
ecosystem and depends on inbuilt widgets
to implement the performance aspect we
discussed because of the bridge from the
code that you write to the native
component access exists in react and is
isolated and not locked any longer
required in flutter and hence the
performance is impacted because of the
additional layer in between the
documentation much much better in
flutter because it's a closed ecosystem
and they can control what you can use
react native being open-ended it really
has a lot of third-party integration you
can do and hence the documentation is
not really well organized the popularity
perspective react native much more
popular among html5 css three mer mean
stack developers since it's all
javascript flutter needs you to learn
new skills and you need to spend
additional time for that from a
community support react native has been
there for a longer time as compared to
flutter and hence has a stronger
community support as compared to flutter
and that translates into better job
prospects
in the industry for react native as
compared to flutter so if we were to
give it a score react scores much better
with a total score of 5 leaving flutter
with a total score of 2. so i hope we
were able to understand the differences
between the react native and flutter and
this will help you make better decisions
with planning your career and deciding
which technology you should latch on to
welcome to the session on react.js
interview questions through this session
we will explore the most commonly posed
interview questions that you would face
if you walk up to a developer interview
on react.js let's start with going
through and exploring the general set of
react.js interview questions that would
be commonly asked in an interview the
first question would be what are the
features of react.js now right through
this session we would follow a common
methodology where we would explore the
question and then look at the best way
in which you could have answered that
question if posed to you during a
react.js interview so starting with the
first question what are the features of
react so react has many extensions for
complete application architecture
support jsx is used with react to
describe what the user interface should
typically look like react is broken into
small components so you look at the
complete application you want to build
break it down into individual components
and a component is typically a piece of
user interface like a function that
would return a stream of html characters
speedy performance is one of the core
features of react as only the updated
components need to be re-rendered on the
screen and not the entire page the
one-way data binding feature on the
other hand keeps everything modular and
fast the virtual dom is also a
lightweight representation of the real
dom which is again a feature with helps
speed up performance and avoids a full
page refresh and a full dom tree shake
which really speeds up performance so
what is jsx how do you answer this so
jsx is typically the extension used for
react and it's nothing but an extension
to the javascript programming language
because all that you can use inside your
browser for execution typically has to
be javascript because in html5 you
cannot have any third party plugins
installed in the browser and that's the
reason the browser would only ship by
default with a javascript runtime engine
so by using jsx you can write html
structures in the same file that would
contain your javascript code as well
making the updates to the code very
simple so it's simple to update and make
modifications to your code because the
code and the data and the business logic
is all composed in a single file so
because the code and the business logic
is in a single file it makes uh updating
and incorporating change requests uh to
the code very simple and easy so it's
basically used with react to describe
what your user interface should look
like and it's what you typically would
term as the html template or the view
coming to the next question can jsx be
directly read by the web browser so web
browsers cannot read jsx directly now
why is that well the reason is simple
it's because they are only built to read
regular javascript objects and jsx is
not a regular javascript objects it's a
react component so for a web browser to
read a jsx file the file needs to be
transformed into a regular javascript
object and for this there is a
javascript api called babel which is
internally used by react so what do you
understand by the virtual dom that we've
been speaking about in react so react
gives a very lightweight representation
of the real dom the actual dom structure
of the page so dom is document object
model it is an api created by w3c and it
creates an in-memory representation of
the html elements as an inverted tree
structure a balanced tree structure
which is the fastest search algorithm
when you want to search for html
elements and do a dynamic update on them
but again updating the basic tom tree
structure of the page causes a full page
refresh and if you only want to update a
specific component you wouldn't need the
entire page to be refreshed and that is
where react comes in it uses a virtual
dom which is a layer on top of the
actual dom which ensures that only a
certain part of the page is refreshed
and that speeds up performance so when
the state of an object changes virtual
dom changes only that object in the real
dom instead of updating all the objects
and this is what makes things really
fast so why use react instead of other
frameworks like angular first of all
it's very easy to create dynamic web
pages dhtml where you can update the
view or the template at runtime the
components are reusable so you reuse
rather than reinvent the performance is
great since you're working with the
virtual dom you don't need a full page
refresh the unidirectional data flow
makes data move one way there's no
two-way data binding by default and
that's the reason the page does not have
to do a lot of heavy lifting of
remembering whether the view is changing
whether the the base javascript entity
class is changing and that saves a lot
of processing time again to debug react
is much more simpler and that's what
makes it more popular in terms of its
simplicity and speed as compared to
other frameworks like angular what is
the difference between es5 and es6
standard so these are scripting
standards okay that are defined by the
european computer manufacturers
association or ecma and all of the
scripting languages
are a subset of the standard and are
derived from these standards to ensure
that the code will execute on all
browsers and the code that we are
writing is standards based so these are
the few instances where es6 syntax has
changed from es5 if you look at the es5
first syntax at the top we're creating a
simple react class component and the
render function just returns a stream of
html content in ex6 there's a new
keyword that comes in which is extends
so you are extending from the base react
component and creating a custom
component and then returning a stream of
characters also the function keyword no
longer needs to be used so the exports
versus export also changes so you use
exports to export out class from a
module so that it can be accessed from
another module in es6 you simply say
export and the component require versus
import so you would require a third
party component or an api into your
javascript file to use it in es6 it's
replaced with the import statement very
similar to the syntax that we use in
code java so how do you go and create a
react app first you install node.js as a
base platform which you can download
from the node.js website next any text
editor of your choice could be atom
visual studio code or sublime text third
you create a react app using a command
prompt
terminal depending on the os you are
using the command to give is create
hyphen react space my first app okay so
the command that you would give to
create a new react app is create hyphen
react hyphen app space and the name of
the application you would want to create
in this case it is my hyphen first
hyphen app and that could be a custom
name of your choice so what is an event
in react well on the web when you talk
about dynamic html it's all about
interacting with the user so the user
performs some interaction event with the
web page which could be a click of a
button a mouse move and these events in
action can be triggered by a user or any
system or could be pressing a key or a
mouse click etc and in response to that
event you would execute a block of code
which is called an event handler so here
we have class simple which is a custom
class that extends the base react
component the name of the function work
which triggers a simple alert message
box and a render function which returns
html when you click on the button we
would want to bind that to the event
handler this dot work and that's how you
connect a click event to an event
handler function what are synthetic
events in react well a synthetic event
is an object which acts as a cross
browser wrapper around the browser's
native event it combines the behavior of
different browsers native events into
one api which makes sure that the events
are consistent across different browsers
and this brings in the standards based
development to ensure in this digital
age the code that we are creating for
different browsers have consistency in
terms of its execution so here we see a
function action link we see a function
handle click which takes e as an event
parameter e dot prevent default ensures
that there is no error that the browser
is raising in case the event function
call is not directly compatible with
that specific browser so prevent default
is used to suppress any browser specific
errors or crashes and a simple
console.lock which will lock into the
developer tools window which says you
just clicked a link and then we've got
the return where we are returning the
view to the html template where on click
we connect to this event handler called
handle click so handle click is
basically a wrapper and the entire
action link is
a wrapper object which is a synthetic
event we don't directly go and bind to
the on click and then associate a
function with it we actually associate a
synthetic object with it which binds the
base default event that could be
specific to a browser so some browsers
would probably understand an on click
sun another browser would understand a
click and to ensure that it's
consistency of syntax and from a
development perspective the code that we
write will run on all browsers we need
to take care of using the synthetic
events which isolate the developer out
from the complexity of writing code
specific to different browsers so you
just write generic code which will work
on different browsers so how do lists
work in react so the list display data
in an ordered format the traversal of
lists is done using the map function so
here we see there is a function called
list of names which takes a variable
props as a parameter props dot names
will allow us to get a reference to all
of the array of names that are passed
constant list names is another variable
created equal to name start map and
we are using the arrow operator which is
now an ecmascript standard and
again we are using the opening tag of
the li html element the key is equal to
the name attribute so the brace bracket
will bind that to the name attribute
then we just print the name itself and
we close the ally tag so that's the
names.map function and finally we return
in an unordered list the list names
themselves so the map function will run
through an iterate over the list of
names list them in the li tag the li tag
will get injected into the unordered
list and will finally get returned out
as a stream of html elements in the next
code snippet below we create a constant
variable names we are associating it
with a set of five names and we simply
say render list of names names equal to
names the moment we do that
we are using list of names as a custom
html element which is not system defined
it starts looking for the function list
of names passes the names area to it
iterates over it using the map function
which is an inbuilt react function
brings out all of the lists it's very
similar to a forward loop that you would
write for iteration in other programming
languages and then finally what you get
returned in the get element by id app is
nothing but a list of
simple names wrapped in a li element
that are printed on the view so why is
there a need of using keys in lists so
keys are very important in the code
snippet that we saw due to the following
reasons the first reason the key is a
unique identifier if you would want to
search for a name in the list it is used
to identify which items have changed
updated or deleted from the list so if
you want to perform cloud operations on
the data you would want to search for
which element do you want to update or
delete or change it also helps to
determine which components need to be
rerendered instead of re-rendering all
the components every time and it
increases performance as only the
changed components have to be
re-rendered and not all the components
on the page what are forms in react so
using forms users can interact with the
application and enter required
information whenever needed so forms can
contain certain elements such as text
fields buttons checkboxes radio buttons
etc and forms are also used for many
different tasks such as user
authentication searching filtering etc
how do you create a form pretty simple
again create a custom component called
name from that will extend reactor
component we create a state variable
this dot state is equal to value we
handle the change by writing a handle
change event and we handle the submit by
writing a handle submit event in the
change event we just change the state by
saying set state of the value to event
or target dot value event being a system
defined keyword passed as a parameter
and in the submit we simply alert that a
certain name was entered and we trap the
value that was entered into the form
prevent default to suppress the browser
from raising any errors on the render
function we return a form on the submit
we connect to the handle submit event
and we bind the data submitted from the
form to the handle submit event and we
pass the this pointer which is a
reference to the current context of the
view itself we open a label specify the
name we then specified input box as text
the value is set to this dot state dot
value and on change we simply connect to
the handle change event and bind to it
and pass the context of the text box
itself so the moment we change the value
in the text box as we are typing the
handle change event will receive the
updated value and set the state and when
we click on the submit button the handle
submit event handler executes and we
alert out the current value printed in
the text box and that's it so how do you
write comments in react when you're a
developer if you want to comment out
some code or if you want to set comments
to enhance the maintainability of the
code a single line comment is as simple
as given in most other programming
languages backslash asterisk to open
astrix to close multi-line commands
follow the same syntax and can span
multiple slides to add comments to
functions in terms of what the function
can do and what are the types that it
can return what is the arrow function
and how is it used so an arrow function
is a shorter way of writing a function
in react if you look at the snippet on
the top my input on change equal to we
are connecting to this dot handle change
dot bind and that's the longer version
of how you can connect it to an event
handler the shorter version is on change
equal to e arrow operator this dot
handle on change so you don't need to
call the bind explicitly you can replace
that with the arrow operator and reduce
the amount of code that you typically
write how is react different from react
native so react and react native are
completely different react was released
in 2013 it's a web-based platform it is
html compliant it generates html views
it uses css for styling and it's based
on javascript html and css react native
on the other hand is targeted to
mobility devices it's meant to create
installable apps on android and ios
released in 2015 not based on html and
css and it basically requires the
react.js api to create these installable
apps for these mobility ecosystems how
is react different from angular another
popular framework by google so angular
created by google completely based on
the model view controller pattern works
on the real dom layer and requires a
full tree shake at the tom layer to
update views and components supports
bi-directional data mining the rendering
is purely done on the client side the
performance comparatively slow react.js
on the other hand created by facebook
it's the view layer of the model view
controller pattern it works at the
virtual dom layer and it sends faster
it's unidirectional data binding and not
two-way and the rendering is typically
what is done at the server side and what
you get as a response on the client is a
stream of html characters as an output
let's talk about and discuss some
questions around react components so
what are components in react so these
are the building blocks you can think of
them as lego blocks so you break your
problem down into small parts each part
identifying a certain solution of the
problem which is what we define as a
component so they are building blocks of
a react application and a single app
usually consists of multiple components
so it splits the ui into independent
reusable pieces that can be processed
separately a component is essentially a
piece of the user interface or the html
view what is the use of render method in
react so it is compulsory for each
component to have a render method if not
there wouldn't be any html for the
component to render on your view so the
render function returns the html which
is to be displayed within a component
like you see on the screen there is a
class app that extends the react
component and it returns a simple h1
element called hello simply learn and of
course do remember to export the app out
so that it can be accessed from other
components as well if you need to render
more than one element all the elements
must be inside a single parent tag like
a div or a form what is state in react
the state of a component is an object
that holds some data within it the data
would influence the output of the
component now how do you implement state
in react so state holds the data that a
component renders on the web application
for example here we've created in the
constructor this dot state equal to and
this temporary anonymous object has two
attributes car and by when we return we
simply return this dot state dot car and
this dot state dot by now this is how
you would create stateful components and
access the state properties within the
view how do you update the state of a
component by using the built-in set
state method you can go ahead and update
the state of the component so here we
have a simple render function that
returns the state itself state dot
message and on the on click connects to
a button press function the moment you
click on the button the button press
function sets the state to another
message so the initial message in the
constructor is welcome to simply learn
the moment you click on the button the
set state triggers and changes it to
best place to learn so the data on the
view would be updated what are props in
react well props is just a short form
for properties and that is what allows
us to pass arguments or data to a
component props are passed to components
in the way similar to that of attributes
that are passed to an html element so
how do you pass props between two
components so let's say we have an
app.js component on the top and a
main.js component at the bottom at the
top we are trying to return this dot
props dot car and the bike so two car
and bike attributes associated with this
props of the app component in the main
component when you look at the render
function we are associating car prop
equal to a value of 1 600 cc and bike
prop equal to value of
150cc and to access it if you look at
the import statement we are importing
app from app.jsx and this is how you can
cross-access properties from one
component within the other so what are
the difference between state and props
well state holds information about the
components they are mutable they can be
changed they cannot be accessed by child
components and they cannot have state
props allow to pass data from one
component to the other as an argument
they are immutable they are read only
and props can be accessed by the child
component and they can have props as
well what is a higher order component in
react so these act as a container for
other components which helps in keeping
components simple and induces the
reusability factor they are generally
used when a common logic has to be used
by multiple components that's when you
group together a set of components
within a higher order component in react
how can you embed two or more components
into one this code snippet demonstrates
the app component which returns a hello
text and it has a custom tag called
simple the simple tag is defined in the
component below and it returns text
called simply learn and in the render of
the react dom uh we simply go and render
the app component so hello simply learn
would be the final output and that's how
you can embed one component into the
other using this methodology what are
the differences between class and
functional components so stateful
components would extend react component
in this case and if you could look at
the render it simply renders
this.props.title the constant stateless
component would be equal to props the
div tag returns this dot props dot title
so you can look at the style very
different in terms of class and
functional components one using the
arrow operator one using the traditional
class and render method so the class
component can hold or manage state
complex as compared to stateless
components can work all of the life
cycle methods of the component and it
can be reused the functional component
cannot hold a managed state they are
simple and easy to understand it does
not work with any life cycle method and
it cannot be reused let's explain the
life cycle methods of components we've
got kenish initial state which is
executed before the creation of the
component component did mount which is
executed when the component gets
rendered and placed on the dom should
component update which is invoked when a
component decides any changes to the dom
and returns true or false value based on
certain conditions component did update
it is invoked immediately after the
rendering takes place component will
unmount which is invoked immediately
before a component is destroyed and
unmounted permanently let's move to the
react redux set of questions so what is
redux it's an open source javascript
library used to manage application state
and react uses redux for building the
user interface what are components of
redux the first is the store which holds
the state of the application store
contains state which defines the user
interface which triggers a set of
actions which are then sent to the
reducer so store holds the state action
is the source information for the store
and reducer specifies how the
application state changes in response to
actions sent to the store what is flux
well flux is the application
architecture that facebook uses for
building web applications and it works
in this way the action is triggered
which is sent to the dispatcher the
dispatcher sends it to the store the
store sends it to the view and the view
sends it back to the action and that's
exactly how the steps would continue in
sequence so when we trigger an action
the dispatcher will get notified once
the dispatcher has dealt with an action
the stores listening to it will get
triggered the view gets updated when the
state of the store changes user action
at the view is sent to the dispatcher to
then be processed how is redux different
from flux redux is an open source
javascript library used to manage
application state the store state is
immutable it can only have a single
store and it uses the concept of reducer
flux on the other hand is an
architecture and not a framework or
library the store state is mutable it
can have multiple stores and it uses the
concept of dispatcher let's look at some
react router questions what is a react
router a react router is a package which
is used to create routing in a react
application react router is used for
developing single page web applications
it allows multiple views in a single
application by defining multiple routes
in that react application how is react
routing different from conventional
routing react routing has a single html
page it uses or the end user rather
would navigate multiple views within the
same file called a single page app the
page does not refresh since it's a
single page file and there is improved
performance since you are not navigating
across multiple pages conventional
routing each view is a separate html
file the user would navigate multiple
files for each view the page would
refresh every time the user navigates
which would hence result in slower
performance how do you implement react
routing you can implement react routing
using a very simple method considering
the above components let's say you've
got a component called app about and
contact so here you can specify the
route path if the route part is just
slash the route defaults out it takes
you to the app component if the route is
slash about in the url given by the end
user you automatically navigate and
activate and load the about component
and if the url is slash contact it would
take you to the contact component let's
talk about react styling questions how
do you style react components either you
use inline styling by using simple css
by simply saying color blue and that's
going to be the output of the h1 element
or i could use a javascript object by
specifying a constant simple style
object and specifying a keypair value of
color background color margin font
family and apply that object as the
style parameter which would result in
this styled output how do you style
react components using a css style sheet
so here's an external style sheet so
we've written all the styling rules in a
separate css file app.css we've imported
that at the top of the app.js react
class and lo and behold you have the
output simplified as generated on your
page let's explain the use of css
modules in react so a css module file is
created.module.css
is the extension the css inside a module
file is available only for the component
that is importing it so there are no
naming conflicts so dot button is the
css styling inside button.module.css
and that is what we've imported from in
the app.js file so when you view the
button style start button is the styling
picked up from the button.module.css
file and so with that we come to the end
of this full course video i hope you
found this video interesting thank you
so much for being here keep learning and
stay tuned to simply learn
you